Melissa, we're good.
We'd like to welcome everyone here today.
Yeah, yeah, zip it.
Welcome everyone. If you want to stay in the council chambers, you need to stop
talking. Okay. All right, we'd like to welcome
everyone. I'm Melissa Clark. I'm filling in as mayor pro tem today. Mayor Gray is
online with us until about 5:30, but he's
asked me to conduct because I'm here in person. This is the work session
for July 21st, 2026, and it is 4:00
PM. And we are going to start with our discussion
and information items. Our first item on our discussion agenda
is an overview of Best Friends Animal Society programs. And this was a
request brought by Councilmember Hewish and Councilmember
Whiting. And I'd like to give Councilmember Whiting just a quick second
to talk about why he asked to have this on the agenda. Well,
I think there's numerous reasons, and I'm grateful that you're here. This is awesome,
and we're excited to hear from you. And I don't want to take too much
time explaining it, but I love cats and I love animals, and apparently
Councilmember Hewish is on board with enough of that as well. But there's, I think
there's some awesome tools that they can provide to the city to improve
the way we, we care for animals in our community. So awesome.
So we'll invite Kate Hall and Bailey Tolton from
Best Friends Animal Society to come up to the microphone and
present to us.
Okay, awesome. Can you guys hear me okay?
Okay, we're gonna kind of tag team this. So I'm gonna start the first half
and then I'll turn it over to Bailey. But my name is Kate Hall.
I am a campaign strategist with Best Friends.
And thank you so much for having us here today. We're super excited.
Thanks to Councilmember Whiting and Hewish for allowing us to
be here. And we met with them previously to discuss some of this. So we're
just super excited. In your packets, you should have received 2 documents from
us, I believe. The first one is an ordinance review.
We do this quite frequently throughout the state of Utah and throughout the country.
This was requested to just see how your city ordinance is doing, if there's
anything you can do better with pets, anything you can do better with community cats,
things like that. And the one thing that we found that we
would recommend is to update to accept
the Community Cat Act. That was a law that went into effect, I think it
was 2011. The legislature passed, but it's an opt-in,
so cities have to add it to their ordinances.
Recently, Cedar City and Salt Lake have added those. And so the
language that you see before you is language that we've copied from Cedar City.
So our legal team drafted that. It should be applicable.
You can put that right in your ordinance if you want to.
So that is the first document, and I'm happy to answer any questions. I'm not—
I don't have a legal background, so I'd be happy to pass
on any questions that I don't have the answers to, to our legal team and
get back to you. The 2nd document that you have in front of you is
this Utah County resources. It just has 4
different ways that we're offering to partner with cities in Utah
County, one being the ordinance review. So you've already done that,
which is great. The 2nd option is to put some
information on your website. American Fork, the city of
American Fork, has done that. And so I'd be happy to share that link with
you guys. You can also just Google American Fork animal control,
and it should pop up. But they've added some resources.
They've added a phone number for us, and it's actually decreasing the workload on
their animal control because we're responding to more of the
complaints about cats that city members might have,
and they're able to prioritize those higher priority asks
from the community. So that's one thing. Another is to do community
canvassing. So if there's areas in your city that, you know, you have
a big colony of cats, And you know that you have some neighbors
that are great and they love the cats, and then some neighbors that might
not love the cats. We can do outreach and we provide free deterrents
for people who don't want the cats in their yard. They work very well.
We can set them up. They're free. And then we can also provide resources for
the people who do like the cats. So we have a clinic here in
Orem, actually, that does spay and neuters for just a dollar. So we
offer those services too. community members. Um,
and then the last thing that we offer to partner is the Community Cat
Program. So that's doing an entire pilot program. Um, it includes
a lot of these other options as well, and I'm gonna let Bailey kind of
talk more about that because she's the community cat expert. So.
Hi, everyone. So my name is Bailey Tolton. I actually live
in Eagle Mountain, um, in City Center. I've lived here since 2020.
I love our city. Um, it's been a great place to raise my kids.
I do work for Best Friends as the community cat program coordinator.
So, um, I'm not sure if you know this, Utah County
is the only county in the whole state of Utah that is
still euthanizing healthy animals in our shelters.
Eagle Mountain's animals go to one of those shelters and
Um, those— not only
are we paying for these animals to go to the shelter, but a lot of
them don't have great outcomes. Eagle Mountain, with us
becoming so big and so many people moving in, we've seen
an increase in how many cats from our city have entered
that shelter. Um, Cedar City is
similar in size to us, and they have started a community cat
program. I did try and get data. from them regarding
how it's going and was unable to do that.
But I did find a study that was published in New Mexico, or yeah,
Albuquerque, New Mexico, at their shelter. And when they
started their community cat program, it reduced
the cat intake by 37%.
Feline euthanasia decreased by 84% by
having this program. And the live release rate
was 47.1%, meaning almost
48% more cats left that shelter alive.
Um, why this matters to me and why I think it should matter to Eagle
Mountain. Um, we all want our tax dollars to be spent
wisely. I know you guys know that, and I know the citizens know that
as well. Um, I think this is a great opportunity for us to be proactive
with our growing city. I think it is a great
opportunity to use our money to have our
animal services money to help animals be reunited
with their owners versus us paying for them to be killed
in our shelter. Um, the cats that
are killed in our shelters, I— they
don't deserve it. I think the root problem is people being irresponsible
pet owners. Thank you. I don't think it's fair that these cats have
to die simply because we are letting our unfixed
pets outside. So with that being said, I hope Eagle Mountain
will consider learning about how this program has helped
other communities. And I think we have a great opportunity not only
to save lives, but to use our tax dollars more efficiently.
And I think this is a great way for Eagle Mountain to show that we
are compassionate and we are. Thank you. forward-thinking as a community. Thanks.
Thank you. Does council have any questions for our— Councilmember
Hughes? I have a few. Councilmember Clark, can you just maybe
really quickly remind me, one, is there a cost to the program
for the city to participate in what you're doing? And just what does that structure
look like? What's the ask of the city? I obviously, I think it is a
problem. I have a couple situations in my own neighborhood, and I imagine
everyone does in their neighborhoods. Um, how many do you know?
How many cats are going to the— are being euthanized
from our city that are going, I guess, going to that one particular shelter?
And then maybe just walk us through the quickly through the process of you
have a cat, it gets spayed and
is just put back in place to where it was before. Is there a way
that you mark those cats so, you know, if they've been spayed, so you don't
have kind of— Just maybe walk us through. Uh, cost and then process.
Yeah, so I can do the cost piece and then I'll let Bailey. Yeah.
Um, so the cost would be free to the city. We're offering these as just
good faith and, um, and free program. Um,
like I said, it's a pilot program. Um, and so we have—
we've made a couple proposals. The last one we put together was from American Fork.
We haven't officially signed anything with them yet, so it's not currently in place.
Um, but what we agreed to with them was a 1-year pilot to
see how much it would decrease the workload on animal control officers,
um, see if it would decrease the intake on the shelter and
what percentage. And then we would reevaluate in a year and see if
that program is worth their time, if they want to continue it.
Um, we offered a few years ago to do this with Provo, and they wanted
to do a 3-year program. Um, so it kind of just depends on what
you guys are, are wanting to do. Um, but eventually,
when we've done this in other areas, um, after we do it for a number
of years, it actually decreases the problem enough to where we're not putting in
any more resources, and the, uh, the animal control officers
are able to take over the program fully without any increase
to the budget because the cat population has decreased so much. So they're not having
to spend as much resources. So I hope that
makes sense. Yeah, and then as far as how
many have entered the shelter, I know in May of this year we— it
took 14 cats Um, last I checked from our
grandma requests, it was 14 cats specifically from Eagle Mountain.
We do offer $1 spay/neuter to the community, and we have
seen an increase in those from Eagle Mountain showing
up to get the community cats fixed. I don't have an exact number
on how many are from Eagle Mountain, but we do have that data that
we can send you. And then, as far as how we know they're fixed,
when they go to the spay/neuter clinic, we ear tip their left
ear, I believe. Um, and that ear tip indicates
that they have been spayed/neutered, and we also vaccinate as well during
that time. So, yeah, all of that would be free
to the city if we do a community cat program. Um, and I believe we
also have resources to pick up the animals and transport,
um, as well to the spay/neuter clinic. Okay,
is there any catch, anything I'm not missing? Here. I don't
think so. Um, yeah, we— it would be a customizable plan.
So we would love to sit down with any animal control officers or anyone
involved and get an idea of what their specific issues,
what their specific needs are. We are offering these services because Utah
County has a really high cat population. And like Bailey said,
this county is the only county in the state that is still killing healthy,
treatable animals. And so we, we aren't offering these services
in a lot of other counties. Most of the other counties are running similar
programs through their own shelters. Um, and so
there's no catch. We're just offering to help, um,
decrease the community cat population. So, thank you.
Yeah, thank you. Any other questions?
Go ahead, Councilmember. Yeah, so can you just help me understand
how you guys are funded? I mean, who's funding you? You guys are here working.
It's a job. Obviously, you're collecting a paycheck. So how are you funded?
As an organization, we have a number of donors.
It's a national organization. We're based in Kanab, actually.
So that's where our headquarters is. We actually have the largest animal sanctuary in the
entire country. So if you get a chance to go down there, highly recommend it.
But we have a number of donors. We also partner with a lot of rescues.
And so a lot of our money goes out to the rescues.
We have a ton of grant programs that we provide them, but it's mostly donors.
It's community members that just want to help. Out in their own communities.
Um, some people will have specific things that they want the donations to go
to, like Utah-specific projects. Other people will just say, here's $20,
do with it what you need. Um, so most of it is donations.
We're a nonprofit, 501.
Um, with other communities that have used
the program or a similar program, and they transitioned
from a kill shelter to a no-kill shelter. What has that process been like?
And have you guys played any role in assisting those
communities to know what they should be doing and how to implement that?
Yeah, so we have a lot of different programs. Um, like I
said, we're a nationwide organization, um,
and we've played a hand in a lot of shelters, um,
going from no-kill to— or going from not yet no-kill to
no-kill. Um, and for those not aware of that term, um, no-kill is
just language that we use in shelter world. Um, and it means that shelters
are hitting a 90% save rate. So 90% of the animals that are going in
there are having live positive outcomes. Um, we recognize that
some animals are going to be sick and they need to be euthanized and they're
suffering, or there are unfortunately dangerous animals that we don't want back into
the, to the community. So that's what that 10% buffer kind of accounts
for. Um, and so we just recently, we helped
2 states. Montana recently just became an entire no-kill state. Wow.
And I think Idaho as well.
And we've played a role in a number of Utah shelters. I think when
we started in Utah, about a 3rd of the shelters were no-kill, and now
we're up to all but 2, and there's 59 shelters throughout
the state. And how that process works is we work with
each individual shelter to assess their needs. So sometimes they need veterinary
assistance. And so we have an embed program. We will send veterinary
assistants or actual veterinarians into a shelter to provide training,
to help kind of with that workload and then
ease them off of it and get them going. We also provide grant programs.
So if it's an issue of funding, which I know a lot of municipal shelters
have not enough funding, and so we provide grant programs.
So just things like that based off of what individual shelters need.
Awesome. Thank you. Any other questions before we Is
there any direction or thoughts that council would like to convey
to staff? I'm supportive of this, but so would we bring this
back up at the legislative portion of our scheduled or
our policy meeting? I think we can make a motion then. Yep. Because I'm supportive.
Same. Awesome. Okay, thank you. Thank you so much.
We'll invite Kiara Poole and
Elizabeth McNanny, just a clarification.
The last one, you mean at a future meeting? Because it's not on the agenda.
Legislative priorities. Oh, legislative priorities. Okay.
Yep. All right, as they're making their way up, they're going to talk to us
about our program year 2026 Community Development Block
Grant funding priorities and project planning. So, ladies.
Sweet. Thank you, guys. Um,
Okay, we thought this might happen, so we have a quick little
backup detour. I'm gonna let Elizabeth introduce—
she's gonna be presenting, and then I will hook this up. Okay,
I'm Elizabeth McNanny. I work with Resource Consultants,
and I've been working with the City of Eagle Mountain for
the last few months and kind of transitioning,
helping to transition the CDBG program back in-house.
My background is I've worked with HUD programs for probably
15 years. I've worked with federal programs kind
of all across the board, everything from Federal Highways to USDA,
as well as HUD and Treasury for about 20 years.
And I am excited to be here. Thank you,
Council, for having me here today.
Yay! Okay, we can just go right past the front
page. Do I, do I have a clicker? Does this work?
Okay. All right, we'll talk
about just the overview of entitlement funds. It'll be a quick
overview and an overview of what's in the annual action
plan. Kind of next steps, because you'll be seeing me again in
just a couple of weeks, and I'd welcome any
feedback.
So Eagle Mountain is an entitlement community, and to be an entitlement
community, you must have 50,000 people as a
city and not also
be involved with an urban county.
So there are cities that have the access to
entitlement funds, but they choose to still run
their funds under an urban county. So Eagle Mountain has been an entitlement
city for 2 years. We have just started the 3rd
year, and we'll talk about that as we go through this.
So CDBG is a formula process,
and there is a YouTube video about how HUD determines
the annual allocation. It is Super riveting, if anyone
is interested. So this really targets—
these funds target housing and community development
activities, really aimed at households that earn
80% or below of the area median income.
And HUD funds are received directly rather
than through the state as an entitlement community.
So, just to kind of give you a baseline for what the 80%
means, you can see here, these are the updated numbers.
They came out last month. A single-member household
can earn up to $66,750 and
qualify as 80% area median income.
So, anything below that is eligible for Any
household below that is eligible to receive funding
through CDBG with certain caveats.
So, the CDBG program, the primary objectives are
to develop viable urban communities,
primarily for low and moderate income persons through decent
housing and a suitable living environment and expanded
economic opportunities. A lot of times that's talking about
Housing, public services, and the built environment.
There are national objectives. Every activity that is undertaken must
meet a national objective. The most common one is benefit
to LMI households. The next one, prevent and eliminate slum
or blight, is very restricted with
very specific caveats that must, you know, things that must
be met before that can be used. And the 3rd one is
address an urgent need. You would never use that one unless
HUD tells you you can. It's typically a natural
disaster.
So the core principles are again to benefit LMI
persons and communities and community participation and
leveraging and partners. You'll see in the next couple of slides,
there's not enough money in the CDBG program for Eagle Mountain city
to solve any one challenge that you might face,
but it's about strategic and targeted investment.
Things that are eligible: housing rehabilitation,
economic development, public services.
Here's kind of a list of public services. This is definitely not exhaustive.
There's a much longer list. But these are some.
You have supported subsistence payments, meaning utility
assistance, as well as food pantry services
within Eagle Mountain City through CDBG previously.
Public facilities and neighborhood improvements. You have also worked with
the senior center with upgrades there.
Things that are ineligible.
Fundraising. Normal expenses of the government.
Income payments. We can't write checks to anyone.
Buildings or portions thereof used for the general conduct of government.
Typically, the purchase of equipment is disallowed.
Maintenance and repairs. So the difference is, if you
have a park in an eligible area and the service
area is eligible, You could do upgrades, but you can't
mow the lawn. So that's kind of the difference there.
Activities affecting multifamily structures or public facilities,
including infrastructure, must guarantee that
51% of the beneficiaries
are low to moderate income, and activities related
to single-family housing developments must serve 100%
low to moderate income, because it's looked at household
by household. And many jurisdictions require that
their public services primarily try to serve at least
100% or close to 100% LMI
clients. So food pantries and, you know, the utility payments
and things like that. And no project is really eligible if
it doesn't meet that 51% income benefit.
So for 2026, program year 2026,
which started July 1st, the CDBG
award is $246,979.
Of that, planning and administration can only use
up to 20%. There's also a cap on public services.
So public services are capped at 15% of your entitlement
award. So that seems— it's low. A lot
of communities would like to use more on direct services, but HUD
to this date has not made that possible. There are some
changes hopefully coming down the line that
may change that in the future. You right
now have an opportunity over the next year because
you have a significant amount of prior year resources.
You have a bucket of funding that's about $220,000
that has not been allocated and has not been spent.
So that increases the amount you have available
over the next program year. Prior year resources
unfortunately do not increase your public service cap, and they
do not increase your administrative cap. So your public service
funding available For program year 2026
is about $36,000, and administration and
planning is about $49,000. So you can see
there you have a little over $380,000 available for other
activities. And in
a 5-year consolidated plan, basically you have the
overall plan, the 5-year plan, and then every year
you have to have an action plan that drills down a little bit deeper.
For HUD to tell them your priority projects for
that year. So we are in year 3, and you will see me in
a couple of weeks with a proposal for the 3rd-year annual
action plan. Here are some
of the components. You've got, of course, your executive summary and
lead organization, expected resources. You'll see
exactly what we just went through on the previous slide.
Slide about resources, annual goals and objectives,
and projects. You'll also— in the plan,
there's some sections for housing and non-housing
needs. This is not like a housing needs assessment. This is very
prescriptive. It's HUD speak.
So you start with needs which are only in the consolidated
plan. And then you have goals in your consolidated
plan that flow down to each of your annual action plans.
So you could have 4 or 5 goals, and only 3
might be captured in any individual action plan. They don't
all have to flow down. And then you have projects.
Those are— these are the buckets. You have projects in your
annual action plan, housing.
Public infrastructure, public services, things like
that. And then the activities are really a function on the other
side. It is the reporting side of ITIS, the discrete
activities that you're undertaking.
This is kind of a flow way to look at this. Create a suitable
living environment might be a need. Public facilities and public
infrastructure improvements may be a goal.
Public infrastructure improvements to benefit LMI
Eagle Mountain City residents could be a project,
and ADA upgrades in X area
of Eagle Mountain City could actually be the activity.
And ADA upgrades you can do pretty much
anywhere, as long as they're not specifically
targeted to kids. Because kids
are not a presumed benefit for,
for HUD, but adults with disabilities are.
So ADA upgrades are really fantastic ways to
increase access for members of your community to important
places.
So outline of possible projects,
rehabilitation and preservation of housing.
Homebuyer assistance. Support for affordable
housing development. HUD, it's a Housing and Urban Development program,
but you cannot build housing with CDBG
dollars. Neighborhood improvements, again, ADA upgrades.
Park upgrades in eligible service areas.
So you really have to look at where the park is,
and then you have your service area. And is that 51%
LMI? And then public facility improvements.
Senior centers are, are definitely pretty easy because the
beneficiaries are presumed benefit for HUD.
And no project is typically eligible if it doesn't meet at least
the 51% LMI benefit.
So the next steps, again, I'll be back here.
in front of you in a couple of weeks to do a presentation and
hopefully adoption of the annual action plan.
And we can't submit to HUD until that happens.
And I
would happily stand with Kiara for any
questions. All right, council, what questions do you have?
So I have a question about the rehabilitation and preservation.
Are there guidelines with how that can be utilized? To rehabilitate
or preserve an existing home? So it would be typically if
you're running a housing rehab project or activity,
as long as the homeowner is low to moderate income,
and it really is identifying and addressing
a deficiency in that home. So replacing roofs? Yes.
Main sewer lines, exterior siding,
things of that nature. Yeah, health and safety issues primarily,
and ADA upgrades again are easy to do, are low-hanging
fruit for our aging population. I am included
in that bucket. So, what about the
absence of landscaping? Maybe their property's gone completely back to dirt.
Does that include— not really. Okay, that typically— just want to know where the boundaries
are. Yeah, it really is about addressing deficiencies
in the property, and if you're running more of a beautification program
that's outside of the scope typically of CDBG.
I got a handful I'm going to lay on you. Excuse me. We had
a conversation earlier before the, before the meeting started. One of the things I wanted
to suggest, and I know that these, these ladies have agreed to look into it,
to the council is whether or not there's an opportunity to use
some of the CDBG funds to support the purchase of
water shares. for affordable housing. We're going
to look at an affordable housing project that we're talking about, perhaps using that as
a tool. And so these ladies are at least going to look into that,
and I would recommend that if that's feasible and there are not too many strings
attached, that we at least consider it. Um, I'm intrigued
by the ADA, and one of the things in my mind that comes into play,
especially with $381,000, $382,000, is how much
of that could be used on ADA improvements in the city. And I would defer
that perhaps to David, to our traffic engineer, and see
if we can identify some areas in the city where we could use that.
I certainly think the intersection on Ranches Parkway
and SR 73, although I know that's some state property,
maybe that doesn't work. But I really would like to see some areas in the
city where we might be able to use those resources. And then an additional question
is, can we, can we, can we utilize those
funds for trail connectivity between some, some intersections
where it's nonexistent? Um, to help that,
I'm sure there's going to be some, some guidelines we have to use.
It would, it would depend on the area and the service area
that you're connecting. Would it benefit primarily
low and moderate income? Well, so I think that maybe that's where
it would be really beneficial to us, Kiara, if we knew that in this area
we probably would meet that 51% threshold, and in this area
we won't, and maybe we could target that a little more specifically.
The challenge with that is it's not just this area
is LMI, it's that the service area of what your
improvement is, who are you serving with your improvement?
So then you have to look at that, and that has to be primarily
low mod income. So it's not just in an eligible area.
So can you help us identify some areas that might qualify?
Because I, because for me, that's an impossible task. I don't know where we should
even be thinking about. Yeah, I think for trails specifically, that That one is a
little tough just because of the overall demographic and the population
of Eagle Mountain's income is quite high.
Um, and so to say, you know, we, we can, we'll get creative no matter
what we do. Um, but we do just have to consider the overall,
I guess, group when we do stuff like that. And that's why kind
of like seniors, like more specific targeted demographics are
easier to get away with. Intersection improvements that would change something from
an area that's not ADA compliant to an area that becomes ADA
compliant would be eligible. to use some of these funds for that. Okay, I want
to plant that seed. Yes. And then, uh, the water we
talked about, $88,000. And then my next one, you led right into it, is the
senior building expansion. I think we should be considering that, being the
senior liaison and the only senior on the council,
recognizing that they're stretched to the limit even with the improvements that
we've made because of our growth pattern. So I, I, I don't
know what that looks like, but that's an area where I think we ought to
at least consider spending some of the resources. Yeah, we'll definitely get with their
team. That's one of the not easiest, but kind of straightforward
paths that we've seen with this. So what about widening a sidewalk?
That's because we have some that are really, really narrow that
would allow for wheelchair access. Would that fall under? I mean,
because I know intersections are pretty clear. Well, if we
have a sidewalk in an area that is in, in that particular LMI.
to make it accessible and safe for wheelchair use, or even for walker
use for that matter. Does that fall within those same
guidelines, or is that— you got to get pretty creative to try to prove
that? Is that what the issue is? Okay. Yeah, you need to get into the
weeds a little further. But the ADA portion about it is what makes it easier
to get into the weeds. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Thanks.
Just kind of bouncing off of these 2 comments,
you know, the local park I lived by for many, many years,
There was a pavilion,
but from the sidewalk to the pavilion, there was no connection
for a wheelchair. We had someone in our neighborhood, we would carry her wheelchair up
to the pavilion anytime, and that's been resolved. So I
just wonder, in some of our neighborhoods, maybe Zach Hilton
or others might know where some of those areas are that we could make those
easy connections. One of the things I'm thinking, Councilmember Hewish,
is is even if we just dedicate a, a preponderance
of this to intersection improvements, then it lightens the burden on the city to perhaps
make those connections or those widenings that might need to happen between those intersections.
So it just— anyway,
I'll leave it there. And the one caveat with that is looking at
if something is already budgeted. So if it's in the budget, you can't supplant.
If you're already planning to do something, you can't Plant it with federal funds.
What about like on a long-term planning, like a 5-year plan or something like
that? Yes, if we haven't like allocated funds in that fiscal year. You mentioned
that you'll be coming back in August with some sort of proposal
for us. What are you basing that proposal on, just the feedback you've heard today
or feedback at previous meetings? What will that consist of?
So feedback from today, also meetings with stakeholders,
some of your nonprofits And, you know,
what the needs are in the community, but definitely we'll take
what we're hearing today and incorporate that for sure.
And we have incorporated some— like, we're thinking about some feedback
that Steve Mumford has helped us gather from the Community Services Board.
So they did provide some good feedback, and we don't
live in Eagle Mountain, so we rely so heavily on that feedback. Just, you know,
what are the needs? What things Do you guys see? And then we take
it and get creative and try to bring something that works.
One thing that I'd like to encourage my fellow council members to consider supporting,
and I hope that it makes it back in the proposal, are some of these
principal pantries and like our library food pantry,
and then the pantry that's at Rockwell. It's got a teen center associated
with it. All of those things serve individuals
who are on the LMI. eligibility,
and I love that we've put a lot of resources into
our senior center, but I also think we need to look to some of those
younger members of that LMI eligibility
and make sure we're taking care of them as well. Mayor Kim Clark, I would
just say this. I agree with that 100%. I, I don't think that we should
shy away from the 15% and 20% buckets that we've been talking about.
I think we should absolutely continue the utility billing assistance.
I think that we should, we should do all of what you just suggested,
but we bump up against limits. And, and what
I'm seeing is that that fund grows and we don't want it to carry over
year to year. We want to put it to work. So the food would hit
the 15% limit, right? That's part of the 15%. Yeah, yeah,
I agree. I think we need to max those out and then, and then use
the remainder. And those ones are fairly straightforward to max out. Same with our admin.
It's the, it's the additional funds that right now you guys see it rolled over.
That starts to create other issues for us, and we don't want to— we don't
want that. So if we can just get the money out, we have a couple
pockets that we mentioned. ADA senior, there's certain areas that it's
easy to say, hey, these are project areas, and we can just get creative
on how that fits Eagle Mountain. Are you only able to come to us once
a year? If you see that we've got extra, can you come back to us
and say, hey, we got another $150,000? We can say, well, let's spend it here
then. Yeah, we can. Well, I think we could be proactive with that.
So if you see that, I think all of us are in agreement it shouldn't
be sitting somewhere. Let's spend it. In a little less
than a month from now, we're going to have UTA on demand and
still no viable bus route. But could we
use some of those funds to help purchase passes for
lower-income people? Could we have passes at City Hall
that if you could prove that you're LMI, You could come and get some of
those things to help with transportation. So that would bump
up against the 15%. And so far, and this year you
did have an application process. This was before I was working with
Eagle Mountain City, and you received 3
applications. I don't know if you guys recall, they came and presented.
Yeah, so those, and those are the— and they're looking
to be able to obviously utilize public service dollars. So, right.
Awesome. Thank you. Any other questions before we have them sit down?
Thank you. Thank you guys. All right, we'll invite Beth Fuchs up. She's going
to talk to us about the wildland urban interface standards.
And as you guys remember, this is bringing this back to kind of address small
lots, and she's seeking some feedback from us.
Apologize for the delay, but we got it worked out. Okay,
so we have discussed this before when we were doing our
WUI map. We Brett and I spoke with
the fire officials and talked to them about ways we could make our city safer
for fire hazards, particularly wildfires.
And we came— I came and spoke with the council
before, and there were some concerns with some of
the things that were presented. And so I've gone back to the dry board,
have a few other suggestions to see if
it's something we want to do, or if we'd Don't want to go
in that direction. Sorry, it's not advancing.
There we go. Okay, so that was the background, and I did also
want to let you know that HB 215 that was passed by
the state does have some changes to standards
that we're not allowed to prohibit residents
from clearing vegetation if they're within the WUI boundaries.
So I will be bringing that back to the council, but I wanted to see
if we were going to do anything else to see if we bring them back
together, or if I'll just bring that one back. So, after our discussion,
I got thinking and want— I'm a visual person. I wanted
to see what this would look like, what the impact would be on the residents.
And I know one of the concerns was having standards that would limit
certain residents from being able to fully utilize their land,
where if they live somewhere else, they would be able to do different things.
And so, as I looked at that, I looked at some
of our larger lots, Particularly those that already had a 35-foot
rear setback, because that would then allow
them to have 30 feet of defensible space for their property.
And so, as I got looking at that, another thing that comes
into play with that is accessory dwelling units,
because our current code requires that those meet
the setback standards for the primary dwelling unit. So,
in that, that would prohibit from putting an ADU
in an extremely hazardous area where,
where they would be exposed to a fire, and that's already in code.
And so I took kind of a standard lot with the minimum frontage for a
half-acre property. And then one, some of these areas are more
challenging areas, so you could have some oddly shaped lots. So I kind of did
the 2 extremes to put them together. And if you look,
The orange areas are where someone would be able to place an
accessory dwelling unit or any
accessory structure and have it 30 feet
away from that and be able to have that 30 feet of defensible space.
We also talked about, though, that really where it's 30 feet of defensible
space, not necessarily a 30-foot setback that we're concerned with.
I also looked at The opposite. So what if instead it
was 30 feet spacing between structures? And so
these are— that's what this would look like.
And as I was looking at this, I realized
most people aren't going to build a huge accessory structure in the middle
of their backyard. You're going to probably put it closer to the home or closer
to the rear of the lot. And so on a larger lot, I think where
people would naturally place those structures. would allow them to have 30
feet of defensible space. So we could, if you wanted,
instead of looking at a setback standard,
look at a minimum lot standard. And if
they had the— we would be looking instead of mandating something,
facilitating it, make sure that lots in those areas were large enough
that they would be able to easily enjoy
the use of their property and still be able to provide 30 feet of defensible
space, or the other. Recommendations by the state when
they come in. And if we were to move forward
with this, that would kind of take care of rear lots. We would need to
decide if there could be whole developments that wouldn't have a side yard
that would be impacted. But if it did, how would we want to address protecting
those? We wouldn't necessarily need to accommodate it all on the property.
We could do it with like a trail or a road or something so
that there is still 30 feet of space between the home and
the improved wildlands. And I
also wanted to just clarify, I'm just— I
was talking about having this only apply to boundary lots, and that
what I brought before only applied to those adjacent to
wildlands, not property that's against
unbuilt areas. However, the state will be coming in and assessing
and charging These were all properties
within the WUI. So we, if we did something, we need to
decide, do we just want it to be there? Would we want it to just
be along wherever there isn't
development? Because if it's against an area that isn't
developed, not could be developed, but we don't know when,
you have that kind of interim hazard. And for example,
what happened in Roy yesterday, even if it's not a wildland,
you can have fast-moving fires come in. So we need
to think about and consider things like that.
And it— Councilmember Wood brought up and recommended
last time that we had these discussions of informing residents
that they're in the WUI, that them know. And I think
that's an excellent idea because they may choose to place an accessory structure
in a different location with that knowledge, or choose a different material type. or things
like that, and they'll understand and can maybe when they're
putting in their landscaping, take into account some of those state recommendations
instead of having to change things later.
And so I just also put in the WUI map to remind
us where these areas are. And again, some of these areas could fall out of
the WUI, especially as they're being developed, but they're probably going to be
certain properties that are always going to have that wildfire lit. risk,
especially if they're near washes or hillsides, things like that.
And these I just put in for reference if we needed them.
And so those were kind of my thoughts based on our previous discussion.
How does the council want to proceed? Do we just want to move with state
requirements, or do you want to consider any additional standards?
Can I just ask a question on the unplanned buildable
area? Is that a requirement of the state? Or is the requirement
just up against unbuildable wildlands? So it's just where we've defined
it on our map. That was just to kind of illustrate different
situations we could run into, because some of those WUI areas are going to be
surrounded by developed land. Some will have undeveloped lands,
but they— that aren't in the WUI. So it's
just different things to consider.
I'm wondering if it would make sense to whoever owns that land to have
a 30-foot defensible space instead
of putting that on the property owners. Oh, like, so there'd be
a buffer built into the development around the edges? Yeah, that'd be my preference.
Could we give like open space credit or something like that
with that? What do you do when it's a government agency or it's
a different municipality?
Because a lot of times you're talking about the area around
the outside, like Silver Lake, Saratoga. You could have that right up against
BLM land. You could have that against county land. So there's
some challenges. I agree. I think the responsibility needs to be shared
both with those who have structures on their land and those that don't.
Yeah. Any other thoughts from council? Councilmember Wright?
Councilmember Whiting. So what is— so what if you have 2 WUI lots back
up against each other? Seems like you could have 15 feet on one side and
15 feet on another side of defensible space. And would that— would
that work? You have 2 WUI lots backed up. I mean, how would
you get 2 WUI lots backed up? That wouldn't work. That wouldn't be a need.
I'm just curious, how would that become the requirement? Because it's really the border,
right? It's the outside. So it's the WUI area, but I guess as you develop
it, that WUI area sort of decreases. But your buildings are
permanent. But your buildings
are there. Like, if you are on that boundary
lot, you put in your 30-foot setback, that building's there.
I guess that's a risk you take buying that
property. Beth, I'm— I mean, I want to share a couple thoughts.
I'm a little confused. I'm going to— and that's easy
to do with me. Um, it seems to me that the half-acre
standards that we already have create a 35-foot backyard
setback. So I don't see that as an issue. The issue is really the side
yard, is what I'm hearing you say, and then perhaps whether
or not we require half-acre lots or larger on the periphery.
I think that's really the question that we are looking at.
I feel a little ambiguous about this because it's, do we,
do we, do we impose additional standards on something that we're
not required to for safety? That's the first question that perhaps we need
to address as a council and, and speak to.
The other issue too is that we know it's going to change. I mean,
the reality of it is you impose something on somebody that is a very temporary
nature. That, that's the concern I have, is that it
Because it's just what Councilmember Whiting said. Well, what happens when you get 2 back
to back, right? What happens when we annex and it
changes? Um, so I just— it's a moving target.
Uh, that's why I, I think it— I understand the purpose
of it. We're trying to mitigate fire spreading, and,
and I think everybody's on board with that. I think we've demonstrated
that, but we've got to be careful with legislation that has a moving target.
On it that can change, and we're putting a
burden on a homeowner to do something that is a temporary thing
that they are going to have the— I mean, are they going to be reimbursed
when it gets built up against them? The answer is no, right?
So they're going to have to make this investment into that until the
developer behind them decides to complete theirs. And once that's done, they're no longer in
WUI. So I just— things like that, I have some
consternation about because it's I don't,
I don't love imposing restrictions that cost money that
are temporary. We know it's going to eventually change.
But I also think there needs to be something in place that at very minimum,
they should be required to clear it, but they should be able to build something
on their land also. Like, I don't know, I just, I'm struggling
with this one. Beth, you had something? Yeah, I just wanted
to clarify. That's why I was looked more at
the lot size, because there wouldn't be any additional requirements
on those residents than any other resident who owned
a half-acre lot. The, the 35-foot setback's
already in place. It just allows them to be able to
put in, to clear the land if they wanted to.
And then also the side, if we had it through a road or a trail,
then it's the developer who's putting that in. They would have the normal 15-foot
garage side setback as other residents. So that
was more the direction. So it shouldn't change anything.
They wanted a half-acre lot, they'd buy a half-acre lot and have the same rights
as anybody else in the city who had that. Could we consider— I
mean, my thought process is, is could we just consider as part of a development
application that the developer make an assessment about the WUI and that
we require that to be reviewed as part of any new development that comes forward.
Because I think at that point in time, you can look at each individual piece
on its merits, and understanding
that it, it may change, it may not change. I don't know,
I'm just throwing out— I'm spitballing here.
Regardless of what we do, I think staff should be sure to inform the
council that we're dealing with a WUI area. Now, some of these areas already have
vestings and entitlements, Some do not, but I think
it would be worth working with the developers of those properties
to try to make them safe. And I'm not saying
these are the best and the only ways. I just think it's something that we
have an opportunity most other cities don't to take these into
consideration as we're approving development. And so,
just being conscientious of that and trying to find ways to make sure that
our residents are safe. Thank you. Councilmember,
I mean, I do like the idea of spacing the buildings apart,
having that 30-foot setback between the primary residence and
a barn, or— to me, that makes sense. I have
no issues with that. I can't remember who
brought it up, but somebody said something about requiring half-acre lots on the periphery.
Is that something that we want to pursue and have be a
part of this conversation, or?
I'm almost thinking we have
so few. I mean, we have— there's areas, right? But we almost need to look
at this as each development application comes through. Okay.
That's what I'm thinking. All right, anybody else have any thoughts
they want to share? Well, I mean, I mean, if you just take an example
of the Horizon development, right, it has entitlements on it. I mean, some of those
lots are going to be bigger. There is some open space that is at least
being considered there. And obviously there's changes that are occurring there,
right? There's at least contemplation, but that's kind of
an island in the city. And at what point does that no longer become an
island? And do we really impose those standards on an island? Those are
the questions that are going through my mind, and I don't know
that one size fits all.
And maybe the contemplation
should be against those Those lands that are BLM or others.
I mean, maybe that's where the contemplation should start. I don't know. So, well,
so what I'm hearing is that it's
a unique situation every single time. So we really probably should
be adding a review of this to every development process
and ask staff to alert us so that we can have the
discussion when we have the factors unique to that area. Is there anything
else we want to instruct staff to work on?
I liked Councilmember Wood's suggestion about a plat notation and disclosure
requirements. So, you know, buyers know that they're in a WUI area.
All right, it sounds like— did you get the feedback you needed from us?
Yes, so I'll bring back the state requirements and the plat notation.
Okay. And if there's a way for us to make it a required step in
our design review process or whatever, because we still want
to know if it's an issue and we want to make sure it's part of
what we're doing. So I'm gonna ask a question of David. Do you mind?
Do you mind if he comes up so I can ask him a question?
Oh, David Yuleberry. Absolutely. Go ahead.
Nice shoes,
David. Love your shoes. Yeah, just in
thinking about this, I mean, I understand all of the reasons that we're trying to
mitigate some of these things, but it feels like we're putting a huge
amount of, uh, onus on small lot
property owners, which generally speaking are not
the ones that are spreading the fire. It's usually on large lots. Have you
heard anything from the state, from any of the fire organizations
where they're talking about Creating defensible spaces on
some of these large pieces of land, whether they belong to the— an
individual property owner or to the state or to the federal government.
Are you aware of anything where they're talking about that? Or— If they're in
the WUI area, they're required for those, whether whatever the size of the lot
may be. So those larger lots are required for those 30 feet if they're in
a designated WUI area. It just depends on what city
they're in. And they would designate those areas.
Okay, that's good to know, because I don't think that was clear to us.
How are we notifying them? Because basically, when we started with the map, you get
an area that they would define by the definition in
a WUI area. But there were plenty of areas in our city map
that were— it wasn't actually— the topography wasn't dangerous.
It was prior to development that they were marked as
that. So there was a few areas in our own map that we changed out
of that. From— that was initially red
flagged as in the WUI area, and that's up to the individual cities
to go through those maps and make those changes.
So it's not just specific to homeowners, it's to actual just
landowners. Yeah. Okay. And so we can— and you go through and you have to
make your argument, obviously, as to why it should be exempt from there.
And we went through that in quite a few areas. Thanks for
the clarity. Yeah. Anything else? All right,
we're moving on to our next item. Uh, Rob Hobbs will
be presenting a discussion item, proposed private purchase
of 0.13 acres of the ranch's golf course.
Mr. Hobbs.
Thank you, Mayor Pro Tem, Council. Staff was approached by,
uh, Ms. Bree Folsom, owner of property at 3544 East
Royal Dornoch Drive, with the request
to purchase adjoining or abutting land, some 1.13
acres of golf course ground.
Uh, that they have an interest in. The golf
course is willing to sell the ground,
as indicated by an email, which I inserted into your packet.
And so the question is, is the council agreeable with this land transaction?
If so, then we will instruct the applicant per se
to go ahead and apply for a rezone, as well as a
plat amendment, a minor one at that. Okay.
Sorry.
While he's pulling that up, does anyone have any initial thoughts
that they want to share? Well, the initial question I have is, I mean,
I know this borders Ranches Parkway. Is that land
in any way contemplated in an expansion? And it's probably far enough
off, but I just want to ask the question.
I— where's Mr. Salazar?
So I think you were a part of some of the conversations that we had
with this particular piece of land and the right-of-way
acquisition for Ranches Parkway. Based off of the image of,
like, the overhead map, is any of this in risk of us needing to
acquire it for our road widening projects?
For the widening, no. I think we talked about using it for some
public works access or utility access in
this area. Okay.
Any other details from staff? Not this time.
Okay. Council, what other
questions and insights do you have?
So would we need to retain some kind of easement to access that
property in the future?
That was the only question I had. Was that question for Brad Hickman
or Marcus?
So right now it's golf course property, so it's subject to
that agreement, which does allow us to have certain rights of
access for public utilities and so on.
Um, if it were sold to a private party, um,
we could, as part of, uh, the reason
that they're asking our permission is because there's the reversionary, or there's the clause
in the, in the, in the contract, right? And,
um, and so the,
um, we could condition kind of
releasing our interest in the property on them, uh,
Grant an easement.
Okay, I think— yeah, so for sure go after some sort
of easement. Councilmember Wright? Yeah, I want to raise another concern.
I mean, recognizing that it is part of this, this agreement, and,
and not, not everyone will probably agree with me, my concern
really is, um, allowing this to be sold, uh,
without having something in place that indicates where
those resources go, knowing that there's some, some debt that
exists. Um, I, I'll probably leave
it at that, and it may be something that we need to discuss in another
setting, but I want at least the council to, to, to have some
contemplation about that. Any other thoughts
from anybody on that? Well, you know, when a, uh, I mean,
in a similar circumstance like this, uh, if you sell off a piece of your
land and you have a mortgage on it, The mortgage
company is going to want some of that money to come pay off some of
that debt. If you're in arrears. Yeah, or just even if there's
a lien against any of the property, even if it's not in arrears,
but even if you have a lien against the property, the mortgage company is going
to require if you sell a part of it, that part of their balance comes—
gets reduced as well. And maybe that's something
that we're going to need to have a discussion about outside of this setting.
Okay. Any other comments from staff? Any other
comments from council? All right, let's move on. Our next item is going to be
also introduced by Rob Hobbs. Um,
and it is a discussion item about the Triumph subdivision. Now,
this is later in our agenda as well as a possible action,
but we also have the applicant here.
Do you like to start? Council,
the Planning Commission advanced this to your bench
with a positive recommendation upon having reviewed the matter.
This is a combination of master development plan and amendment,
uh, an agreement amendment.
The Triumph subdivision was entitled a few
years ago, and at that time was given a residential
Setting and zoning. The applicant is
interested in, as you can see by this exhibit,
creating at least 4 areas that would be for affordable housing.
The city has already dealt with affordable housing comments
in the past, especially by staff promoting the
idea. The applicant has a few asks as detailed in the staff report.
To make the project, quote unquote, affordable.
And they are here, as you already indicated, to explain what they
would like to do. But essentially what you have are open-air
tandem parking spaces with private roads built to a city structural
profile, but not with the full right-of-way width, et cetera,
that the city's schematics require. Okay.
And then you have a select set. They had 3 samples shown to
the commission of possible house designs that would work
for each of the lots. We would have reduced lot sizes and expected
setbacks as well. And that would make it, uh,
for them pencil out better. They think that'd be an introductory
comment. Any questions? Any questions, counsel?
All right, can we invite the applicant to come up?
And field some questions.
Please introduce yourself. Are we
on? There we go. Scott Hazard. Thanks for your time today. What questions can
I answer for you? Council, what questions do we
have for this applicant?
I'll jump in. I mean, I got a lot of different notes, but Okay.
So, oh man, I got a few questions. I like, I love the affordable housing
purchase price cap because that sort of
solves one of the issues I was contemplating a few days ago is that if
you have a family size of 8, they could, their 80% of what they could
buy, the purchase price would be much different than a family size of 1.
Then someone could buy in as family size is 1 and then turn around and
flip it to a family size of 8 and make a profit. But that's,
so I like the introduction of the cap. Based on the numbers we just saw
from the CDBG
presentation, it looked like the 80% AMI
of a 2-household was $76,300. If you
do a multiplier of 3.25, that puts you at a purchase price just under $310,000.
So that sounds good. I mean, is that sort of what you're anticipating?
That's at 80% AMI. We will not be below $310,000.
So our starting homes will be probably more like $325,000,
$329,000. Okay. So that multiplier— so that multiplier,
I think, caps where you would be. So in other words, that multiplier would be
below— we would need to increase that multiplier in order to
go to $325,000 because otherwise our current multiplier is hitting us
at $309,968 for a max purchase price. You're talking about for the deed restriction?
So, the, the multiplier sets in
after the first sale. After the first sale. Yeah.
And the intent is exactly what you just described, where we didn't want
to just let an equity grab happen because as developers, we're leaving
a ton of money on the table to make this work. Um,
and we're all— obviously, there's also a lot that the city's contributing to try to
make this work, at least that I'm asking you to. So, we didn't, we didn't
want gen 1 of buyer to just benefit and then
take a, take a bunch of money and bail. So,
so we've created that restriction as a multiplier so that purchase
price will always scale with AMI. So it's—
we felt it was better, and we're open to feedback.
We felt it was better than putting a 3% or 3.5% or 4% annual
cap to the purchase price because it allows them to grow equity as
income increases on the average within the state.
And it's always tied— the idea is to service that population.
And so equity gain is basically just tied to income.
Yeah. Yeah, I love this idea. I mean, we all know that
the median income has not kept up with the median home price in Utah.
Yeah, this attempts to solve that problem. It's deeded.
So there's, like you said, you can't buy the property
and then flip it a year later to a higher price. It's always just going
to follow the median income, which is going to help. I think I'm just thinking
of a lot of young starter families trying to get into a home.
It's innovative. Yeah, that the deed restriction was
probably our biggest challenge to bring this back to you in a formal format to
ask for a vote because of those types of challenges and then
getting appraisers and underwriters to sing out of our songbook so they could be Freddie
Fannie underwritten. They can't be HUD-funded, so we can't do an FHA/VA
loan. They won't allow the deed restriction. But there's been a lot
of collaboration and thought with many different parties to
try to get this to a point where we can get loans on it,
we can get it funded. And our intent is that these are,
these are designed to be attainable in perpetuity. All other programs
that I'm aware of in the state cap at like 10 years, and then it's
free-for-all, do whatever you want. I'm like, why did we spend all this time and
effort? for a 10-year program. So tying it to
the AMI, I think, should allow us to, to run in perpetuity.
And then in the deed restriction, we've empowered the council
to make modifications to that down the road if it seems like it makes sense.
We've created some restrictions there because we didn't want you pestered with every little—
everybody wants something. It has to be a market-wide,
industry-wide impact, a community-wide impact. So that you're
not hearing requests from every individual little owner to say, hey, make an exception for
me. Can you change this? Uh, because we recognize 10 or 15, 20,
30 years down the road, the dynamic might be different. Maybe income doesn't
scale nearly as much as it needs to, and there needs to be
some concession. The multiplier might need to change. Uh, so we've empowered
the council to be able to make those decisions. Go for
it. Just one other. Yeah, I have a lot of questions building in my head.
This, these, these pods will be under an HOA.
Yes. Is that correct? Yes. Same HOA as the properties outside of the
whole— Yes, they'll be like an HOA that'll handle just
these attainable housing clusters. But yes. Okay. So,
so maybe this section needs to be clarified because
when I'm looking at the affordable purchase price cap,
one of the sections pertaining to that says,
that any transfer shall be
equal to the product of the resale multiple and the AMI.
And it says any transfer. So I didn't realize— so
when I'm reading that, I was thinking when you're selling it as well, because I
would assume that would be a transfer unless that was defined otherwise within the contract,
within this language here. Colby, do you have a better response
to that, or Kaden? So you're saying for the initial sale? Well,
so, yeah, what Mr. Hazard is saying is the initial sale would not be subject
to the resale multiplier. But I didn't— that wasn't clear to me in the,
in the deed restriction language. If I understand your
question, that 3.25 is a plug for the time being.
When we go to sell these homes in these communities, we will set the multiplier
to equal the purchase price. That makes sense. So that when,
when I'm a new buyer and I purchase the home, the purchase price, if I
take my area median income then and times it by the
multiplier in the deed restriction, it will equal the purchase price that I bought it
for. So we will sell it at the qualifying purchase price and
then from there, AMI will increase their purchase price in the future. So that multiplier
is going to change with every single contract? No. So we plan to do it
on a node-per-node basis because of the cost of construction.
So when we build out phase 2, like the first node here,
we'll have set purchase prices for each floor plan there. And we might have,
you know, 3 or 4 floor plans, but we intend to build them
all out at once. And to get some economies of scale there to further
contribute to the affordability aspect. But so each node will have its separate
multiplier, essentially.
Any other thoughts? Now, this is an item that shows up later
in the agenda for a possible action. Are there any details of
that item that we need to hammer out? Yeah, so I've got a few more
questions. So the, so the one of the asks Is that the
city provide or purchase the water necessary?
I would like, I would like that quantified in terms of like, how much are
we asking? And I think it would be coming from RDA dollars.
How much is in our RDA to actually provide? So that's actually
something I wanted to make a note on. It's a good question.
I think that we need to make it tied to available RDA
funds. So, if that runs out at a future date, that we're
not now taking that out of our general fund to buy water for these.
So, I think that that probably needs to be some language that's put in there
that if the RDA funds are no longer available. And then
the other thing too is I just wanted to be clear, market water that
is on the market, but we're not providing that from our own stores.
Yeah, the proposal has never been for the city to provide
water or to sell water. That's never been the proposal. In fact, I think
it came from Uh, this body, I was the one who suggested it.
I'll take the blame. Yeah. Uh, the idea that maybe RDA
funds could be used to purchase this on the open market. There's 2 variables there
that I think are important for us to define, or at least create a methodology.
Uh, one is we need staff to calculate what's our,
you know, per acre foot, what's our quantity requirement for these small
houses on really small yards. Uh, my sense is it's probably different
than what's in the in the existing table because it's a very different
product type. Uh, minimal outdoor irrigation, very water-wise landscaping,
and very small homes. So that would be one factor
that we would need to determine. The other thing that I think we should insert,
and I've had this conversation with staff but didn't know what number to put in,
is that there probably needs to be a cap on a per acre-foot
number. Um, you know, so I, I don't call
my buddy Isaac and say, hey, sell me some water at $65,000 an acre-foot,
and then the city's on the hook. To pay for it. So I think we
ought to have a methodology or insert a number, something that's reasonably representative of
market value that's still attainable, where we could actually acquire
water at that number. But that's reflective of a market rate. What if we
tied it to what our ability to sell it, what the price,
if we were to use our own stores, we would contribute
up to that amount of money, and then the responsibility for the remaining amount
would be up to the developer. That would just add to the purchase price.
So, I mean, if you think about it right now, right now, it would be
roughly 10% of the cost of the home. What do you get that right now?
$31,000 for an acre foot of water?
Just— yeah, I've seen it sell for as high as $35,000.
So I've been— we'll use $28,000 to $32,000. Say $31,000,
right in the middle. I think right now it's selling, uh, if we sell seed
CDB water, I think it's $21,000, $22,000.
So, yeah, $21,000 responsible for $9,000 an acre-foot.
You're not going to hit a full acre-foot for a house that size.
So, I think it's reasonable, but that's probably
the only way you're going to be able to follow that in a reasonable way.
Has to be tied to something that's fixed. Yeah, that's an amount that is fixed.
The only— I think that that creates some safety for the city. The only challenge
I see with that, Rich, is You know, water is becoming an increasingly scarce
resource. And if water does jump to $40,000,
$50,000, $60,000 an acre-foot, I can't deliver these. There's just no way I can
subsidize that kind of money to make— to hit these price points and make it
happen. Or we have to add it into the price of the home, and then
we've thrown ourselves out of that 80-90 AMI target, which is what we're after.
I think the suggestion that I would make would be,
Scott, I mean, recognizing that that there's some variables
that need to be worked out. I think if we can put together just some
brackets that, that, that you're comfortable with and the city becomes comfortable
with, that makes a lot of sense to me. The other thing is, you know,
I think Councilmember Wood makes a good point, is, is subject to the fact that
there are available RDA dollars to purchase the water. But I think
we should just look at it pod by pod. And, and I know that you,
you know, with the concept that you have in place, you're saying,
look, I just want to trans— I just want to transfer this concept to the
next area, to the next area, with some subtle, perhaps subtle design changes.
I don't know. One of the things that I want to make sure that
we're really focused on— you're saying that you might have 3 or 4 different plans,
and you've shown us some really beautiful designs, at least in my opinion,
that make a lot of sense. I think they're super livable. I think we need
to have the language in there that recognizes you're going to put the refrigerator and
the stove and all those things that we've talked about. out in there. I,
I don't know that that was in there. I didn't see it. It probably is
somewhere and I just missed it. Um, so those are a couple of the things
that I'd just like to see get changed, but recognize that this first pot is
really an experiment. And, and I don't— look,
I think, I, I think it needs to be said publicly that you're being pretty
generous in coming to the table and trying to help us develop this.
I'm really grateful for that, and we're trying to,
to, to help you get over some of those hurdles that you're facing to be
able to deliver a product that's pretty unique. And my goal and our hope,
I think, is if we can't set a standard by
which the rest of the state can learn something, and, uh,
and maybe we can actually start to tackle the real problem
with affordable housing and get our kids into single-family homes.
Yeah, and that's my real goal, Brett. This is not a one-off thing for
me. Uh, I, I see Eagle Mountain leading out with a product like this
to show the rest of the state on what can happen When a willing
city and a willing developer can collaborate and come up with some solutions.
And I'm sure there's plenty of warts we're going to shave off of this first
cluster and then figure out how to do it better in the next one.
The purchase price inclusions that you referenced are not included in the amendment
to the development agreement, and we can incorporate those. I don't have any issue with
that. I just— it's funny when you're driving through
other cities and you see $600,000 townhomes as affordable housing.
I'm like, that's This, this really is trying to solve
the problem, and I'm excited about it. The other thing I'm excited about is none
of these properties can be rented out. They will all be primary owned,
which is awesome. The enforcement of that's going to be challenging.
Right now we're saddling the HOA with that. They're kind of acting as,
as Rob put in the staff report, as a de facto housing authority.
But we'll do what we can as the city matures
and develops, and maybe at some point you've got a housing authority and we can
turn that element over to the city, or maybe we just— I have full confidence
in our HOA Karens to take care of that.
So, so the HOA will take care of the roads?
No. So the only public infrastructure element we've asked
the city to handle are roads and utilities. All of the surface
landscape improvements would be handled by the HOA, including irrigation.
Uh, but maintenance of the utilities in the road and the road itself would
be, uh, would be the city's responsibility. So snow removal,
crack seal, you know, asphalt repair, all of
that would be under the city like you would any other road. Okay, and then
the other, the other, other questions. But so
parking, because then the roads are so narrow, I assume that you're restricting parking
so it cannot be on the street. Yes, but I didn't see that verbiage in
the CC&Rs. There's a section on parking that didn't seem clear to me.
11.6. Maybe I wasn't reading it. Yeah,
we would add a note. We would add a note to the amended plat for
that, and we've worked that out in DRC with the fire chief. I didn't realize
this, but a red curb is insufficient. You need signage. So we'll, we'll,
we'll work on that. But yes, no, no parking on the street
side other than the little razor strips of parking that we've added for additional overflow
and visitor parking. Just for reference, will you just once again
tell us a 2-bedroom is going to sell at— what are you calculating it at
currently? In the low $300s, um, probably $330-ish,
um, for, for 2-bed, 1.5-bath. Uh,
the biggest plan, which is our 2-story plan, uh, we priced out
last at about $374,000, and that includes all appliances.
So that's fridge, washer, and dryer included, includes all the window
coverings. It includes all landscaping front and back
and all the fencing. So all of those things that are really a first cost
outlay for a new homebuyer when they buy a home, then they realize, oh my
goodness, I have all these other expenses. The only thing they really have to worry
about is furnishing the inside. Everything else is covered in the— And my last question,
Scott, and it's really a compliment to you. Is there anybody in the audience that
knows somebody that would benefit or purchase one of these?
I just think this is— I think this is an amazing opportunity to
try something different. Thank you. Oh,
Councilmember Wood, did you have just thoughts? I'm sure we're going to talk some more
about this. I'm not firm on how we
deal with the water, but I want to— I mean, you know,
I'm a workshop. Let's talk about it. Let's figure out something that is scalable,
that doesn't require a lot of oversight. Um,
one of the things I was— when I was looking through the deed restriction,
I am concerned about the city
being required to deal with all the transfer stuff. I would love to see that
be a 3rd party, frankly,
just because that can— things can change and sway and
whatever. And if we want this to have lasting, it needs to be
someone that is actually Running this program, maybe it's a 501
or something like that, that is responsible for doing this, that doesn't have skin in
the game. And I don't know what that looks like, but I really
want this to last. I think, you know, that I'm invested in, in this working.
I believe that this is the only attainable housing product
in the state. Everything else that I have seen develop
is something that is not really producing the outcomes that we're
looking for, for the individual that's buying the house. And I,
I'm proud of it. I think we put a lot of work into this one.
I want it to work, but I want it to be something that's scalable that
we can do throughout the city. I hope other people steal it and want to
do it in the rest of the state, because I think it's a good program.
Councilmember Wood, I'm just going to make a quick suggestion. I mean, we already have
someone reviewing all of our, all of our loan applications for those who are
Or seeking the forgivable loan that comes out of those RDA funds. I just think
that the city could help participate in reviewing that at some point in time.
That's a great suggestion because it's all of her underwriters that we've vetted this through.
So she seemed like the,
the perfect one to manage that end of the process. And so she's
been included all along. So I think all the points and questions
I heard are very valid. It looks like we've got a few things to sort
out. amend, uh, before we're ready to go to a vote. Is that a
fair stand— fair statement? I think we can probably deal with most of these things
in a— in a motion. In a motion, don't you think? I mean, so I
think when, when we come back, we've addressed most of the concerns.
Um, having an administrator do that— Marcus, if you think that we need
to have more strong language than what we've talked about,
tell us now, and we can give them the ability to go and do that.
But I think I don't want to sit on this much longer.
The prices of houses go up as we continue to sit. So,
just so you know, my first phase of Triumph is submitted to staff for
final plat, does not include this, but there's a slight adjustment I'll
need to make in the first phase to accommodate this. And I'm hoping to knock
through this right away so that I can start delivering houses
next, next spring, summer.
One, one. Oh, sorry. Hang on. I want to make sure Marcus answers my question.
You know, I won't have any time during this meeting to hammer out the
language, but I'm sure we could figure
it out. Watch the recording, make sure we encompass everything that's in
there and work through it. That's what the council wants
One thing that's kind of a sticking point for me,
and I'd love to, like you said, workshop this— the water price.
I know that we have to find a target, we have to
find a fixed number. Sure. But I also don't want to automatically
basically underfund the water by like $9,000
per acre-foot. So I would ask that we look at
maybe what market is going for right now. And set the cap
similar to that, as opposed to the Central Utah Water
Project water, because we all know that no one's touching
residential water at that $21 or whatever price it is right
now for us. Yeah, it was just a suggestion.
I think there probably needs to be some sort of a scale. Maybe even
we create some parameters based on, you know,
sales price or Size of lot or whatever.
I think that's one of those moving things. We got to get that part figured
out, but I'm open to suggestions for sure. Yeah, as am I. And I'd still
like— because I don't feel like we have the data on how much
money do we have in the RDA funds? How much money is going to be
required? Like, I don't have that data. Based on that, I would like to see
those numbers. Staff can— staff. Yeah, Evan, you probably could shoot that from the
hip and just tell us. Wasn't it $1.7
million last year was what went into the fund, and that was with a fraction?
Will you say that one more time? And we'll— okay,
so, and, and how many
shares would be required for this project? I'd need
staff to do a calculation for me on that, but my assessment is it would
be on, on a market value per per acre-foot, it's probably somewhere
in the $20,000 to $25,000 per unit.
And how many units are contemplated? There's 32 in this first phase,
and they're all about— they're, they're all a little smaller, a little bigger. But so
30, 32, um, okay,
times $25,000, so $800,000 per pod.
But, but each pod's different than— like, some have more than 32
or less than 32 on these different pods. But tonight's, tonight's discussion would
be inclusive of all the pods, correct?
Or are we only looking at 1 pod with the agreement right
now? I mean, my, my, my, I would sort of favor, given how new this
is, to approve pod by pod, just in, or even pod 1.
Let's see how it goes. And we're like, yeah, this is so good. We're approving
these other, other 3. Yes. And I think your
point is well taken, Councilmember Whiting. I think, I think that what I would probably
suggest is that we enter into this agreement Pod 1,
recognizing and perhaps entitling 2, 3, and 4 for
a similar or a like outcome, but realizing that it's got to come back
so that we can tweak those details that are going to pertain to each
pod. Well, and if we're going to consider
using RDA funds for this, I mean, that's a big chunk of money we're doing.
And anyway, that's where I think is we got to sort of
consider this pod by pod. I think we all kind of are good
with that. So, could we instruct staff in the motion that
this applies to Pod 1, and then we'll come back for the rest of them?
I mean, what do we need to do to get this across the finish line?
Are you okay with Pod 1 being approved? Yeah, yeah, I,
I just, I would want to see this successful, and I think this is,
this is going to require collaboration as we go.
Um, so, you know, my intent is we get through Pod 1,
I'm going to come back to you, even if it were Already vested and titled.
I'm going to come back to you to return a report and say, this is
what went well, and these are targets we totally missed, and this is how we're
adjusting for the next phase. So, I see this
as an ongoing collaborative effort, and you're on the journey with me regardless. I think
we're in the saddle together. And if the biggest issue really is just the water
right issue, you know, we could say, okay, generally we're looking at these 4 clusters
or those 4 pods, but water rights will address on a phase-by-phase
to assess What's in your budget? How much is a prevailing cost
to buy the water? Um, you know,
maybe that's something that we look at at a phase-by-phase to see if there's funding
for it, and maybe we wait. Maybe we don't deliver that cluster in
that timing, and the timing, uh, you know, runs with the funding.
So one more thing to that, though. I think it's important to remember,
even if it had to add an additional $10,000 to it because of the
economy of whatever it is at the time. These are cheap.
I mean, I didn't think that's being lost on people what this affordability is actually
creating that does not exist. So, as we're haggling over
$1,000 or $10,000, recognize that
they are not buying an appliance package. They're not doing
any of their own landscaping,
fencing, Those are tremendous costs that people are
going to have to do with any other product. So,
even if we get close, we won.
Yeah, I agree. And there may be different ways to
help with the offset of the funding. Water just seemed like an element that
we could address directly because it's such a big component. But like on
the CDBG grant, you know, I heard you ask the question about, can we buy
water rights? Well, maybe not, but can we buy all the common area
landscaping as part of the project, and the developer buys his
own water rights. Is there an offset where funding could be used and we
classify it a little bit differently so that the funding can be, you know,
used where it can be used? I think we could have that flexibility built in.
That's an excellent question. And I mean, and I'm pretty sure council's aware
of this, but just for the benefit of my 2 new colleagues, I mean,
those RDA funds are replenishing year by year, and they're growing
at a, at an at a pace that, um,
we're going to have to find a home for them to make sure that we're
successfully using them. Yeah, I think to that
point, if we don't use it, the state's going to come and say,
what's this money you have sitting here, and take it from us. So I'd rather
put it to really great use. Are there any other thoughts from council,
um, that you want to share before we move
on to the next item? Great.
Thanks. All right, thanks, Mr. Hassell. Thank you. All right, so our next item on
our, uh, discussion agenda is city manager
information items. So, Mr. Reeves,
um, the one thing I just really wanted to bring up is that we have
an anticipated July 30th meeting that's joint with Saratoga
Springs. I know that the mayor of Saratoga Springs won't be available that evening.
But this was one where we were going to talk about connectivity of
our 2 communities, specifically all the different connections that kind of follow
the Spring Lake neighborhood, as well as the Lake
Mountain corridor connection. And we anticipated having the
church in attendance because they own a lot of the property there, having the school
district in attendance because they have property there. I just wanted
to get that on your horizon, see if that is— if
there's any specific work that you wanted or needed accomplished prior to
that meeting and how we can best support you in that
endeavor. I will be flying
back from Montana that night, unfortunately, so I won't be here.
But I think as long as you have good
representation— I believe that's at 6 o'clock. What day again?
July 30th.
Next week.
All right. I might defer just to David. David, what do you think that
we ought to— I mean, there are several connections that we ought to be
having a discussion about. I'm just wondering if you can bring some maps
and— And it's probably also important to note that UDOT
and MAG and Avenue Consultants will be in attendance as well.
Yeah, and I think this whole thing got brought up because we had the Lake
Mountain corridor study kind of showing that really great east-west connection,
you know, shorter travel time. And we put on the RTP draft,
Saratoga Springs didn't like that revised layout. They liked the original
one that kind of went farther south and came back up. So that's what
kind of started this whole thing. We can talk about some of the other connections
as well. Wild Blossom. Also the connection to the
east, kind of making Wagstaff Way our primary— Look, it's going to be one of
those really fun coordination meetings where we listen to a
variety of opinions and we try to work to the middle. I mean, I think
that's really the goal, is to hear one another's concerns and to see what
we can do to amend and bend without
breaking to produce the best outcome. That's my hope.
The Wagstaff Way is a good one too. That 122
collector in Spring Run area right now, it tees into that
connection. I think that'd be a good one to also discuss. Hey, can we realign
that portion so that is our main thoroughfare in that region as well?
Any other thoughts? So just to clarify,
those that will be in attendance will be MAG,
The LDS Church, UDOT,
but nobody from Saratoga Springs. Saratoga Springs, it's a
joint council meeting with the 2 councils. Oh, they are coming. Yes. Oh, good.
Okay, awesome. All right, any other
feedback for staff? Ben, uh, do you have any other announcements for
us? Um, I will be out of town, uh, tomorrow, and then
of course, um, our offices, uh, it's,
it's Pioneer Day, um, we'll be Closed on Friday,
and so really Thursday is like Friday. And so just— I'll
make that announcement in the next meeting. Awesome, thank you. All right, so let's move
on to our agenda review. We do have quite a bit to discuss
in closed session, so we're probably going to try to get
through what we absolutely have to and then save the rest for during policy session.
So one of the asks from our recorder's office is that we give
special attention to the motions recorded in the minutes.
Um, and if anybody needs more time, Mayor Gray indicated
that it would just be better for us to pull the minutes from the consent
agenda if needed. Did anyone have any issues or concerns about
the motions in the minutes? Well, I have a— so, one comment on the
minutes. The name Jesse Call— Jesse's name was misspelled
in 3 locations, so it's J-E-S-S-I.
So I just like that noted somehow. I don't know if we need to make
that, or if we could just state it here and it's
good. Yeah, that one's probably good. Anybody else have anything about the minutes before
we dig into the rest of the consent agenda? All right,
moving on. Uh, bond release, Briley North Plat
A out of warranty. Does anybody have any questions about that one?
Pacific Springs Phase A Plat 5 out of warranty.
Okay, and we just talked about the minutes.
The next one is 12A. It's a resolution,
um, appointing a member representative to the North Utah
Valley Animal Services Special Service District Board,
and that individual will be David Yuleberry,
replacing Finn Cofed. Does anybody have any questions
about that item? All right, next, 12B. This is a resolution approving
the 1st amendment to the stadium development agreement. Does anybody have
any questions about that? All right.
Uh, 12C, a resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving
the 1st amendment to the Briley Townhomes Phase
B development agreement. Do we have questions
about that? I know we had that as an item last meeting.
Uh, the applicant is here if you'd like to ask questions,
or staff. Yes. I had one brief question. So lots 207 through 210
had 3-story varieties built on that with the larger garages,
but those were not originally contemplated in the count you needed for 40,
correct? And yes, please come to the microphone,
introduce yourself. Greg Wall with Land Eagle Development,
and we're working with the developers for
the Towns of Reilly Farms Phase B Platts 1. Or 3
and 4. So those 4 lots were in Plat 2, and the language of the
development agreement contemplated lots in Plats 3 and 4.
But those had not been built on yet by the prior developer,
and the home builder Element Homes had the opportunity to purchase them,
and they did that so they could have a model home ready by the
time the construction on the infrastructure for lots or Plats 3
and 4 were completed. So. Yes, it's the exact same model
as the 3 stories with the 600+ or 600 square
foot minimum garages. So you're basically asking for those 4 to count toward the Phase
3 requirement. Toward the 40 overall requirement. The 40 overall requirement.
Does anybody have any issues with that request?
Okay, I thank you. Have a seat. The next
one is an ordinance.
This one is approving the off-street trails master plan.
We spoke at length about this at our last meeting. Does anyone
have any thoughts or items on that?
Okay, so the
next item is a motion to reconsider. The one
of the applicants for that is planning on being here in
the 7 o'clock meeting. So, can we hold the
review of this one off until the next meeting. Great. Let's skip to
the next one. Um, an ordinance of Eagle
Mountain City amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code Section 1620
for preliminary plots, 1625 for final plots,
and 17100 for site plan review.
And I don't know who's assigned to
this one. It's not on there. Brandon Larson. It's me. Thank you.
Um, this is just a
simple administrative— well, I shouldn't use the word simple. You may not think
it's simple, but what I— what we're trying to do here is clean— it's
another part of our effort to try to clean up our development
process. A while back, we ran into an issue
where we realized that we didn't have all the information we
needed to calculate some bond numbers. And so
what we're trying to do is get some of that, get that information
from the applicant at the front of the application process.
It might mean that an applicant might have to
update their cost estimate a little bit.
They may have to update it a couple of times through the process,
a few times through the process, but we feel like it's going to be a
benefit not only to the But to staff, to the city,
to be able to get an idea of how much public improvements
are going to cost. And it's
going to give the applicant, I think, a better— it'll
put them in a situation where they are better taking
more care to plan for their public— the construction
of their public improvements and paying for them. So. Okay. We,
we are proposing this additional
document for preliminary
plats, final plats, and site
plans. There might be another one that I'm forgetting, but we just think
this, this information will be really helpful and help
it so that we don't end up at the— end
up at the end of the development process without a clear understanding
of how much public improvements are going to cost for development.
Thank you. Does anybody on council have any questions or thoughts
that they'd like to voice? Just, I love the plain English summary
for SB 202. We need those on every single thing we're reviewing.
It's nice. Yes. All right, let's move on to the next
one. This one is an ordinance amending Utah Municipal Code
8.15.070, noise levels, and Mickey
Mills is presenting this one. Do we want to have her come on
up? Why don't you come up?
Well, we think that the HDMI cable— so you're either
going to need to go over there. I don't have a ton to show.
It's really just a very short 1 line being added to the code.
Okay, go ahead, Councilmember Wright. Thank you. Hi, Mickey.
I, I just have a question about red lines. I'm, I'm— it's,
to me, it's just a little bit confusing, and I hope you'll help me walk
through it a little bit. And it's in Section D, the hours
of restriction exemptions. Um, I'll let you get
there. So, 1, parks— the hours of noise restriction within any park as defined in
EMMC 7.05030 are as follows.
10 PM to 6 AM. So I'm interpreting that to mean that,
uh, you got to be quiet in the park after 10 o'clock and,
and before 6 AM. And then it says golf courses. The hours of noise restriction
for privately owned golf courses for maintenance activities are as follows: 5:30
AM to 10 PM. Does that mean they can't mow during the 5:30 to
10 PM? They're saying you can't restrict it during that. So that's what the bill
says. Yeah, that's an exemption.
Okay, so they— that's the time when they're going to be able to do it.
Okay, I told you I was confused, so I'm glad that they clarified it.
Does that make sense to everybody else? Just me having a hard time with it?
Okay. Okay, any other questions, comments?
All right, thank you. Um, the last item that
is a regularly scheduled item is discussion,
possible action For Triumph, and we already discussed that
with the applicant. Um, so I think what
would be good is to retire early
to closed session so we can get through the list of things that we need
to do. Would someone like to offer a motion? Pro Tem
Mayor Clark, I move to adjourn to a closed session for the
purpose of discussion of pending or reasonably imminent litigation,
the character, professional competence, or physical
physical or mental health of an individual, the purchase, lease, sale, or exchange of real
property, a proposed development agreement, project proposal, or financing
proposed related to the development of land owned
by the state or political subdivision, and/or the deployment of
security personnel, devices, or systems pursuant to Section 52-4-205
of the Utah Code Annotated. Second. All right,
we have a motion from Councilmember Hewish and a second. From Councilmember
Wood. Let's start the vote with Councilmember Wright. Yes.
And I will vote as a councilmember. Yes.
Yes. Yes.
Yes. Thank you. All right,
thank you.
Here, Councilmember Wright will be offering a prayer for us before we
begin our meeting. Our Heavenly Father,
we're grateful to bow our heads in prayer this, this evening, and we express
gratitude for the opportunity to live in the United States of America,
to enjoy the freedom and just
the gifts that this land offers to us as citizens. We're grateful
for one another, grateful for our staff, for all the hard work that they
put forward on behalf of the citizens of Eagle Mountain, for the tireless
hours that they work, for the sacrifices that they make away from their families as
they strive to deal with those issues that come
up in the middle of the night, on the long weekend,
or any other time that seems to be inconvenient
when those things happen. We express gratitude for them.
We express gratitude, Father, for willing developers who are
willing to come and to invest their money and their
resources in our city in an effort to produce something worthwhile
and something that, that benefits and blesses them and provides
opportunity and, and, uh, allows our citizens
to grow and flourish and for our community to, to be viable.
We're grateful for the economic development opportunities that continue to come to
us and pray that we'll be blessed with wisdom as we
exercise and make decisions regarding them. I want
to express gratitude this evening in particular for the council members, both present
and past, for mayors both present and past, and for
all those public servants including our Sheriff's Department and our,
our firefighters, just for their efforts, for their love of our
community, and for their willingness to sacrifice their time and
to provide their services on our behalf. Pray, Father,
for wisdom and guidance in the decisions that we'll make today. Bless us with
civility and kindness as we interact with one another. And express
gratitude for the opportunity to make and to be involved in these discussions and
decisions. Humbly do so in the name of Jesus Christ. Amen. Amen.
Thank you. And we'll call this meeting to order at 7:03 PM.
Uh, first we have a few housekeeping items.
Mayor Gray is not here tonight, so I'm filling in as mayor pro tem and
conducting the meeting. Um, we'll excuse him. Um,
and then housekeeping-wise, I need to announce that there's
3 items that were noticed for public hearing as follows.
However, these 3 items, only 15A will be
held as a public hearing tonight. So, if you received a public hearing notice
or something like that, we want you to really pay attention to this part.
Um, 16A will not be a public hearing.
That's the ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 8.15.0.0
noise levels. And then 17A is also
not a public hearing, approval of 2nd amendment to the Triumph Master
Development Agreement for the Triumph subdivision. If you would like to comment on
the 2 noticed items, 16A or 17A, You may
do so during the public comment portion of the meeting.
Yes, I know it's next. Thank you.
And next, Councilmember Whiting will lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all. With liberty
and justice for all.
All right, um, thank you all for being here.
Uh, we are going to go right to information items and upcoming events with Mr.
Reeves to provide that information to us. Okay,
uh, thank you, Mayor Pro Tem. Um, our city offices, um, and public library will
be closed on Friday, uh, July 24th. 4th in observance
of Pioneer Day. And because that Friday is closed,
Thursday is kind of like our city's Friday.
So it'll be a skeleton staff that will be here on that Thursday.
We have fireworks that we're promoting at Utah Lake on
July 24th at 10 PM. There's been donations
made, and there's going to be a barge on both sides of the lake.
For more information about the fireworks, That is at
fireworksstate or fireworks at
utahlake.com, and and also too,
we are because of the dry conditions going to be
working with the state of Utah on a ban of fireworks
at your residential homes and and within the city limits.
And so we encourage our community to go support. support this at Utah Lake.
In addition to the celebration on the 24th,
our city itself will be having a celebration on the 25th.
It's called our Summer Bash. It's a laser show, and that'll be from 4 to
10 PM at Cory B. Wright Park. So great events both on, on the 24th
and the 25th. Our Back to School Night is Saturday, August 1st,
from 6 to 8 PM at Cory B. Wright Memorial Park. And then
we have a Truth in Taxation public hearing scheduled for August 6th
at 6 PM, and we invite our public to attend. Thank you, Mr.
Reeves. All right, now we've reached the public comment chunk of
our agenda. Time has been set aside for the public to express their ideas,
concerns, and comments. Please limit your comments to 3 minutes each.
As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for community members
To address the city council, and each speaker is allowed up to
3 minutes. If you wish to speak during public hearing portion,
please complete a comment form located
in the back and return it to the city recorder. So it's on the little
table back there, and our city recorder's up here. Um,
council members will listen but not engage in discussion during public comment.
Disruptive behavior, personal attacks, or comments
about individual city employees are not permitted. If you have issues
or questions regarding staff or personnel, Deputy City Manager
Steve Mumford will meet you in the foyer for further discussion.
Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated
with a scheduled public hearing. If your comment relates to a public hearing
item, please wait until that item is called. And I had
already announced that 16A and 17A do not have
public hearings. But 15A, which is an ordinance
of Eagle Mountain City amending Eagle Mountain Municipal Code, uh,
16.20 for preliminary plots,
16.25 for final plots, and 17 site
plan review regarding application requirements and cost estimates.
So, if you'd like to speak on that one, we ask that you'd wait until
that public hearing takes place. Now, I will open
the public comment period at 7:08. And invite anyone.
Lacey, do you have some for us?
Awesome. Please come up, sir.
Did you say George? Yeah. Yep. Come on up. Thank you.
Please state your name in the microphone. My name is George Reed. I live on
1148 East Ira Hodgins, Janick Parkway.
We have a very, very serious problem about speeding.
On that road. I've spoke to the mayor at
a friend's wedding. Uh, that was what, 2 months
ago? Nothing is being done.
Uh, I talked to Mr. Salazar because he's
the assistant engineer. He said that they're going to do a city
study for speeding. We have had 4 studies done on
Ira Hodges already. We've had the wires put across that road 4 times. Uh,
I talked to Sergeant Gilstrap. I— he actually invited me to do
a ride-along with him, and, uh, he had let me know
that, uh, on the one study that they did, that there
was at least 6 instances of people going 60 miles an
hour on a 25-mile-an-hour road.
I literally had, uh, 2 young men coming off of, uh,
the street next to us. They were coming around the corner. We heard
a bang. He skidded clear around the corner, hit my driveway,
and skidded halfway up my driveway, busted a wheel
and knocked off 2 tires. Being the guy that I am,
I fixed his car for him. I told him to leave it there and I
would fix it for him. So, I try to do everything
I can to make things right. We do have petitions signed
here. We have 50 names. On this, they've talked about
putting us like a speed table. We need a speed
bump, a speed dip,
something to slow everybody down. It's just,
it's out of control. Thank you for bringing it
to our attention. We'll invite you to give the petition to our city recorder.
Ira Hodges was never meant to be a thoroughfare. We know they put
those 2 residential areas to the West of us.
Okay. And so everybody has to come down that road.
I would make a recommendation. It gets
extremely bad as soon as school starts. That's going to be starting here in
August. We would petition that something be done
prior to the start of school. Okay. Okay.
Thank you. Yes, please.
Thank you. Thank you for sharing your concern with us.
All right, Lacy, who else do we have? Shelly Anderson. Shelly Anderson.
Uh, Shelly Anderson, 1176 Ira Hodges. Thank you. Um, we moved
into our neighborhood almost 19 years ago. We've lived in Eagle Mountain for
29 years.
We've been here a long time. We moved out here with the hopes of living
in a small town, which we did for a long time. Moved into
a bigger home because that's what we wanted for our family. We moved into an
equestrian neighborhood because we own horses and we love that.
The equestrian neighborhood that we moved into is supposed to have a golf course behind
it, which was going to be really cool. Fast forward today, we're getting high-density housing,
I believe, behind us. And there's no sidewalks, and our neighborhood
doesn't want sidewalks. Planning Commission, I think,
kind of messed up. The road should be a lot wider. Especially for
all the traffic that has to go through there to get to the elementary,
which we fought when that happened because it wasn't a good thoroughway,
and we lost that battle then. I thank
you for everything you do. I don't want you to think that it goes unnoticed
and it goes unappreciated. You guys do a lot, and I appreciate it.
I'm gonna ditto everything George said.
I about got hit by a car last night, by a motorcycle. As I stood
in the middle of the road and went like this, slow the heck down.
He continued to come straight at me and then swerve around me. We've had
cars swerve into the gravel pits off the road in front of our house.
We had our mailbox plowed over by a minivan a
couple of years ago. We've had a gun pulled on a neighbor because he was
mad at the guy speeding, and the guy pulled a gun on him. We've had
3 kids hit in our neighborhood. It's enough.
The minute someone gets killed, Or wounded greatly,
it's going to be a huge problem, and I want to save that from happening.
Our horse happens to live across the street from us. I have 10 grandkids.
First thing they do when they come over is want to go feed the horse.
I've had cars swerve at my grandkids. I've had them
speed as we walked the Arctic Circle to get ice cream cones. I watched a
little kid wreck on his car, and cars pull over
and honk at a little 5-year-old to get up and get out of their way.
In a crosswalk. It's enough.
We've complained to the sheriff department multiple times. We have yelled
and screamed at neighbors. I'm sure half my neighborhood hates me. I don't care if
I can save one life. If I can save one limb, it is worth it.
It is time to act. I talked to Jared Norton. I'm sure
you all know who he is. He's on Unified Fire. He said enough is enough.
Speed bumps have to happen. Stop signs. I don't care if you put a stop
sign on every 3-way in that neighborhood. People are fed up. Um,
it'd be nice to say everyone would be nice. If everyone could just
be nice and slow down, it'd be great. That's not what's happening. It's getting worse
and worse the more people that live there. So we would appreciate if you'd do
something for it— about it. Thank you, Shelley. Thank you. Thank you. All right,
anyone else? Okay, so that's it for
the forms that we have filled out. Is there anyone else in the
audience that would like to come up and share their thoughts? Go ahead.
If you could fill out a form after you're done and make sure our recorder
gets it, that would be great. Just start by stating your name in the microphone,
please. I'm Justin Hopkinson. I live on 872
East Waddell Street, just over from where they
live. And, and so I got the other entrance to Mountain Trails Elementary.
And yeah, when school starts, it's, it's horrible.
And I adopted a little boy from a cousin's heroin addict,
so he's 6 years old now, has severe ADHD. I have to
keep a death grip on him. Otherwise, he'll run out in the road. And he's—
there's some cars, new people that moved in, that these kids that are racing
up and down the street, contractors that I've yelled at hundreds
of times. And I walked out in front of one guy hauling a big load
of material, and he
yelled at me. He says, you think I could stop? I'm like, exactly. Look at
this little boy. If he runs out in front of you, you're going to be
able to stop for him? Yeah. And it's, it's out of control over there.
And I've called numerous times the police to help
us out. And it's, it's, yeah, it's out of control. And I'm scared
for my little boy and all the other neighbor kids. And yeah,
definitely during the school time that people are going out
of— the parents are out of control. They'll go into oncoming traffic to,
to go around the people, the long line to pull in there. It's,
it's That's horrific. Thank you. All right. Thank you. Thank you.
All right. Anyone else would like to give public comment?
All right, we'll close public comment at 7:15.
And as we do that, I think it's important just to,
um, set the expectation for our city manager that
I think council would like a report back at our next meeting of
how we're going to address Ira Hodges and Just give us kind of
a return and report on that, because we can tell that it's a
significant problem. So, thank you. Happy to do so. Sure.
I'm— I ask the mayor pro tem if I could speak to this for just
a minute. I want you to know that this has been a concern of ours.
Um, we've, we've tried fairly diligently to find some
resolution to several places in the city, and Ira Hodges is one of them.
In this budget cycle, this past budget cycle, we actually funded
$200,000 worth of speed tables. And one of the areas very specifically that
we targeted is Ira Hodges. Uh, I want you to know that, that we've set
money aside for that to happen. We are waiting for our staff to finish up
a report, which we should have in the next week or 2. That's the anticipation,
to make sure that, that the traffic tables that we think are the best solution,
that our engineering team agrees with us. If there's something different that they recommend,
we'll certainly keep you in the loop. Um, but we're very aware of that,
and you're not alone in that concern. There are several other areas that
are adjacent to elementary schools that are really awful in the city,
and we're concerned about it citywide. We're not going to take comments, or we're
just going to— I just want to give you an update. Um, but I want
you to know that we're very aware of it and that we're as concerned about
it as you are. I've been to your home. I've seen that. I've watched it.
So, um, and I think that, that our staff
is really great at listening to us and understanding, but what they don't often get
the chance to do is to come sit and meet with the residents and
And to hear those concerns that you just shared. So thank you for sharing your
thoughts, Shelley, and, and, and, and the rest of you. Um,
anyway, I just want— I wanted you to know that we're very cognizant of it,
that we are making some forward progress for the first time in the 5 years
I've been here, 4 and a half years I've been here. We've actually allocated resources
and we're making— we're making some adjustments. Thank you,
Councilmember Wright. All right, now time has been
set aside for City Council and Mayor to make comments. Let's go ahead and start
with Councilmember Hewish.
Thank you, Pro Tem Mayor Clark.
Government just never moves fast enough. That's the one thing I've learned
sitting here and being on that side, that there,
there's clearly a need all throughout our city. And I just echo what
Councilmember Wright has said. If I could show up tomorrow
with a speed table, I'd probably just put it in. Um, but we want to
make sure that the engineering is right, that we're allocating resources in the highest
problem areas, and, and your concerns are valid and
are heard. Appreciate all that our staff
do. I'm amazed at all the different projects we have going on. It's a
pretty vast machine that's being built in Eagle Mountain, and we have a
lot of infrastructure projects going in. We've got water being built.
sewers being built, lots of infrastructure, and I'm just grateful.
It's amazing that how a city works and functions,
and I appreciate all that you do and, um, look forward to
tonight's comments and agenda items.
Thank you, Council Member Hewish. Council Member Wood?
I'm probably not going to be as warm and fuzzy as Zach was. Hearing you
guys say that just makes me more mad. About our
inaction, frankly.
I mean, I when it happens,
everybody's going to go, "Oh my gosh! Let's hurry and try to fix the problem."
And I just I do not make the excuse
that government can't go fast enough. That is a lie. I'm sorry; it is a
lie. We can. We have the resources to do it. It is
our Unwillingness to do things that are out of character of what everybody thinks
we should do. And I, I'm upset. The same problem exists
in 3 or 4 other neighborhoods where elementary schools are.
It's unacceptable, and I am sorry that we have not
acted. It's inexcusable, and I can promise
you that those who are dragging their feet, if it was in front of their
house, it would already be built.
All right, Councilmember Whiting. So I heard
multiple times we've worked with the sheriff's office on this, that, and the other.
You're all just giving the reasons for a tax increase.
We need more public safety officers, and it's pretty evident.
I think the ones we have are doing a great job. We just need more
of them because we've grown a lot as a city, and they cost money for
them to come in. And so, You know, the tax increase is
going to be discussed here soon and voted on.
And one thing that I'm looking forward to with these additional,
you know, public safety officers is we may be able to get more
patrol happening in neighborhoods, especially to help with speeding and things like that. And I
can't speak to prior, you know, prior studies that were done. All I can speak
is the studies happening now, and I can speak to the resolve of the council
that sits up before you to solve these problems, and it's going to
happen. So you, you can feel the energy that's coming right here. It's, it's going
to happen. We'll bring solutions and as fast as we can. So,
um, anyway, we're grateful for the public comes out and gives us insights
and comments because we need your eyes and, uh, need you, need you with us,
um, to give us, help us, help us make better decisions.
Uh, one last thing I'll mention, uh, be on the lookout for a
new half marathon that will be here in Cedar Valley.
We are in the works to make this happen on October
3rd. More information is going to be coming out. It will be the
I Believe in You Run Cedar Valley, and it's
going to be in partnership with Ben Lyon. And we'll be carrying signs,
and we're going to have a run here that is going to be epic.
It's going to be a combined effort between Cedar Fort and
Eagle Mountain City, who will be co-sponsoring. It's going
to be pretty epic to bring our community together. And money from that is going
to be going toward, uh, this volunteer fire department that
Cedar Fort has, as well as our volunteer police services here as
well. These are some of the things where people say, well, you know,
we want you to, to manage differently so you don't have to raise taxes as
much. Well, this is one of those efforts to bring in money from
businesses and other people who are willing to— the running community— to
where we can then have that money flow into some of our public safety as
well. well. We are looking at other ways to do that, and in this case,
it's going to help with those items I just mentioned and then also help with
unity and, uh, mindset and mentality
in this, in this valley. And I'm really excited about that. So more, more details
will be coming out about that. Thank you, Council Member White. And Council Member Wright?
Well, I took a minute, but I'll, I'll just add one thing that I'd like
you to be aware of. Um, the seniors are putting on kind of a food
drive for the pantry, and I just want to read a list of items.
So if if you have these or willing to donate them to the, to the
food pantry that's in our Eagle Mountain Library here just behind us. Flour,
granulated sugar, vegetable oil, iodized salt,
black pepper, onion powder, garlic powder, baking powder and soda,
white vinegar. And also helpful in the pantry would
be peanut butter, canned tuna or meat, canned milk, canned vegetables,
canned soups, packaged pasta, oatmeal, hot cereal,
white or brown rice. I just think it's important to remember that there are those
in our community that have food insecurities, and anything we can do, those of us
that perhaps have a little bit that we can donate,
those are the types of items that they're looking for this month. I wanted to
make that announcement. Thank you. Thank you. And I just
want to say thank you all for being here. I really appreciate your neighborhood coming
out and sharing some of those very personal concerns and experiences.
Um, we do need to do better, and I think we're working
toward that. Um, and I'm grateful that
no one's been hurt in the way that
we've talked about. I appreciate you talking about life and limb, and sometimes
neighbors get mad because you have to stand up for what's important.
So thank you for coming out for that. And I thank all of my fellow
council members for the things that they've shared. Um, we have some cool things
going on in our community right now, and, um,
We have a really cool communications department that's
trying really hard to make sure our residents are informed of what's going on.
One thing that our community services board has been working on
is a bingo card, and it's a bingo card that goes from,
like, Pony Express Days all the way to basically the end of the year.
And there's prizes and different things that different people are going to be donating
for people who complete their bingo card. But. If you missed
one of the items on the bingo card, there's a QR code on there with
some like makeup items, and we encourage you— it's a really fun way to
celebrate our 30th anniversary as a city,
um, and to participate in that. Um, and that's
all I have to say. Um, I will entertain a
motion for the consent agenda making the minor adjustments
to the minutes as noted during work session.
Yeah, Mayor Pro Tem, I, I move to, uh,
approve the consent agenda with the,
uh, spelling corrections to the minutes as noted in the work session. Second.
All right, we have a motion from Council Member Whiting and a second
from Council Member Wright. Um, we'll begin the vote
with me. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes, thank you.
That passes. All right, so now we get
to go on to the scheduled items. So the first item
is a motion to reconsider, and that is
going to be presented by Lacey Messerly, our city
recorder. Council, this was the
land disposal that came to you last August. It was approved
with criteria on option 1, where all of the residents were to
participate in the plat amendment, and we have had a hard time getting ahold of
one of them. So we're bringing it back for a motion to reconsider.
We've talked about this at length. So the applicant is here to answer any questions.
You want to start with the questions? We can go from there. Awesome. I know
that there are questions because I've had a chance to talk to some of our
different council members. Councilmember Wright, do you— are
you ready with your question? Yeah, I have a couple of questions. I— when
we talked about this most recently, it seemed that there was one holdout.
In looking at the amended flat, it looks like there may be 2. Is that
accurate? Yes, there is one who is getting a divorce,
I believe. Sorry, I turned you off. Um, can you explain that
one a little bit more about the applicant who is going through a
divorce right now? Yeah, so she— sorry,
whoa. She is still planning on buying. She's still buying now.
She just cannot— like, she can't incorporate it until October
next year. And so she still would pay and everything and own it. She just
can't incorporate it yet. So there's only 1 holdout that we
haven't been able to. So I guess my question then, Jesse, is that Lot 63
is shown in the amended plat with that portion behind their lot
as not part of their property. And Lot 66, is that— am I reading that
correctly? Yes. So 63, the one that's closer
to the end? No, 66 is the 3rd lot in, and 63
is in 5 lots, 6 lots it looks like. Okay, so 66
is the one where she— it's not showing as a part of her lot because
it can't be a part of her lot yet. She has to own it separately.
And then the other one is the person we can't get. So, so it's— she's
going to purchase it then. So, okay, that makes sense. It's just separate Yes,
so that it has a different parcel number. That makes more sense to me.
And then can you, can you tell me what the portion is that's identified
as POSIF? And I'm not—
or 1F maybe is what it is. It's a piece of property that's adjacent or
right behind lots 267 and 266,
and I believe that's the Moody's home. Yeah,
yeah. So that's just the, the part that was designated. There was 20
feet we had to leave open for a path. Okay, so that is for the
path, and the city is maintaining ownership of that. Okay, those were my questions.
Other than that, I think it's fine. Any other questions from council?
All right, uh, this is not a public hearing, so I'll
entertain a motion on this.
I'm a little confused as to what we need to do on this. Do we
need to— do we need a motion to reconsider it and then
No, the item is already on for reconsideration.
That happened when 3 council members sent a written statement
to the mayor asking that it be reconsidered. So, at this point,
procedurally, what we need to do is make a motion
to— if you're inclined to approve it, make a motion to approve it and changing
the conditions from what they originally were.
Okay, do we want to have a discussion about what
that looks like? Sure. Does anybody, does anybody have consternation about
removing the one lot, which is, it seems it's 63,
then is the one that is going to be removed, Jesse,
and 66 is still part of that because they're going to purchase it,
right? Yes, they're still going to purchase. So it's just that one.
And what about the timeframe? Because I know the timeframe has kind of been
adjusted. How much time do we need to get this done?
Um, to get it, uh, as far as an agreement done and
all that. Yes. How much time should we— should we— because we're talking about changing
the timeframe because it's expired. Yeah, so I mean, at this point we
have an amended plat that would have to go through the process.
Um, we need 6 months. How long? 6 months is more
than enough time. Okay. Um, um, I have a question.
Go ahead. Will that include like— because with the last one it was moving
the fence within a certain amount of time, but we're going to hit winter now.
So I don't know if we need to adjust that because we had 6 months
from the date of the motion from the last time to
move our fences.
Yeah, I mean, okay. I mean, Council Member Wood saying why don't we give them
9 months. Does anybody disagree with that? Yes. So we're having—
Rich, can you turn your mic on when you're talking? Thanks. I'm just saying that,
that, I mean, they're going to be dealing with frozen ground.
So give them a year. What difference does it make? Yeah, I'm good with that.
It sounds like council's good with giving them a year. Are there any other questions
about what the motion needs to entail?
I'll take a stab at it. Thank you. I know
I'm probably going to mess it up, but Marcus will correct me,
or somebody on the— to my right. Well, maybe somebody to my left will fix
it. I move that we approve
the disposal of $1.5 6 acres of designated significant
real property in Utah County parcel number 49;601;0080,
pursuant to EMMC 3.30.060
and 3.30.070,
with the following changes to the original
agreement: that we extend the timeline to Um,
for this to be done within a year,
and, uh,
that we, that we remove the requirement of Lot 63
to participate in the agreement and allow the other remaining 15
property owners to do so.
Second. All right, we have a motion from Council Member Wright and a second from
Council Member Hewish. Are there any Questions from staff or discussion?
City Council, does it need anything else marked?
I think we're okay. Okay.
Okay, seeing none else, we'll go ahead and begin the
vote. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood? Yes.
Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes.
And I am a yes as well. So that motion passes.
Thank you. Alright, moving on to the next one.
You guys, there's like a legit 3-ring binder up here, so there's
a lot to get. Okay. Alright. So we're moving on to the next item,
and this one is the public hearing. It's an ordinance
of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code Section 16.20,
preliminary plats, 16.25, final plats,
and 17.100, Site plan review regarding
application requirements and cost estimates,
and Brandon Larson has
a presentation for this. Thank you.
This is, as I noted in the earlier meeting,
this is part of our effort to clean up our application process,
particularly the front end of our application
process. And as you noted, it's for preliminary
plats, final plats, and site plans. We found
that we've typically required
a cost estimate towards the latter end of the
approval process, and actually
after the approval process, and it ends up creating a situation
where when we're going to generate bond
estimates. We've found occasion where
the information we needed wasn't readily available. So we
think it's— we believe, and based
on my own experience, and I've worked in another
subdivision process where we required the cost estimate at
the front of the process, and it really
was helpful in Planning for,
uh, planning for improvements
and just understanding the improvements
that are required, and also for preparing bond— the bonds.
So we feel like this is a good improvement. We feel like
this information is already being— we don't
think it's going to be a big ask for an engineer and
the developers because they already have this information. We're just asking. for them
to give it to us earlier, um, so we can
really facilitate a, a little bit smoother development process for them.
So if you have any questions, I'm here to answer. Thank you, Brandon. Does council
have any questions? All right, this is a public hearing, so I'm going to open
the public hearing at 7:34
and invite anyone who has a burning desire to speak about this item
to come up to the front. No one would like
to speak. Seeing none, I'm going to close the public hearing also at
7:34 and call for a motion.
Mayor Pro Tem, I move that the city council approve
agenda item 15A. Is that enough in
the motion? Yes. Second. All right,
we've got a motion from Councilmember Whiting and a second from Councilmember
Wood. We'll start the vote with Councilmember Wood. Yes.
Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Clark is a
yes. Councilmember Whitey? Yes. That passes.
All right, thank you. Moving on to 17A. This is
a— oh, sorry, skipped it. Thank you.
Um, this— it's the only thing we took out was the
public hearing part of it, so thank you. Um, 16A is an
ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the Eagle
Mountain Municipal Code 8.15.070,
and Mickey will be presenting to us.
So we'll just invite her to get set up and
share her presentation. It's going to be a very short presentation.
I'm just going to show you the actual code language. And Councilmember Wright,
you are right with a W. I did,
I, I did mix it up. So when we— if you— if we do approve,
I will need to We'll need to switch the 10:00 PM to 5:30.
And I'm glad that you caught that because the double negative went right over my
head. So, this is just a code amendment moving the
Eagle Mountain code to be aligned with the state code changes. And it's
really just limited to— we can't regulate
the golf public or private golf courses from doing maintenance activities
as it relates to noise between the hours of 5:30 AM and 10:00 PM.
10 PM. Uh, so the exception would be
10 PM to 5:30 AM. Awesome, thank you.
Does council have any questions besides that one update to
it? All right, I'll entertain a motion. Mayor Pro Tem,
I move to approve agenda item 16A.
All right, change that she recommends. Um, well, as presented,
yes. All right, we have a motion from Councilmember Whiting.
Second. And a second from Councilmember Hewish. We'll begin the
vote with— Can I, can I just ask that we clarify that
in the red line, that below item number 2,
golf courses, that it'd be switched from 10:00 PM to 5:30
AM? We just switched those 2 timeframes. I was just going to raise that
issue. Let's make sure we do that. Okay. Okay. Do you need the motion
specifically to say that? I'll withdraw my motion.
Okay, then, if you're gonna withdraw your motion, then I will make a
new motion. And let me get to where I need to be to do that.
Sorry, Councilmember Clark, where is it?
I move that the Eagle Mountain City Council adopt
or approve an ordinance amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code
8.15.070 with the following change to the
red line. The last item under number 2 for the golf course,
that the times be reversed so that it's 10:00
PM to 5:30 AM. All right, we have a motion from Councilmember
Wright. Do we have a second? Second. Uh, second from Councilmember Hewish.
Is there any discussion?
Seeing none, no discussion, we'll start
the vote with Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Councilmember Clark is a yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes.
Councilmember Wood? Yes. And that passes.
All right, now we're moving on to 17A, and this
is Rob Hobbs that will be coming up to present
on this item. This is a discussion slash possible action.
It's a— would be an approval of the 2nd amendment to the Triumph
Master Development Agreement for the Triumph subdivision.
And Mr. Hobbs. Thank you, Mayor Pro Tem. Mayor Pro Tem and Council,
as discussed in work session, we have a request by developer
to amend a master development
plan and agreement that was created with the Triumph project
in 2022. Developer is seeking to create 4
pods, if you will, ranging from about 3.5 to 4
acres, 3 to 4.5 acres around that range,
with some flexibility to be Afforded to the project to
facilitate— oops, pardon— the use of smaller
than normal lots in the foothill residential zone, to basically
grant or get an exception to the buffering standards
that we have in the code for sizing of properties, to also
associate with that have reduced setback allowances.
And finally, to have private streets that would be built to a certain
form of city standard in terms of the subroadbed, et cetera, but not
in terms of right-of-way width. Open-air parking is proposed,
and staff has also— the council has seen in the past representations
of at least 3 prototype houses that could be put into the development. If the
project is successful in providing attainable housing, we expect the applicant
will be able to move on and, and develop his
other pods that he has in concept form. We discussed the water
issue earlier, where the applicant is not going
to be asking the city for water, and also that they will
be helping to orchestrate with deed restrictions the ability
of folks to apply to purchase properties in
this development. Staff recommends this project for your
consideration and approval. Thank you. And stands for questions.
Thank you. And just as a reminder, this was originally noticed as
a public hearing, but it does not need a public hearing. So just
as a reminder, in case somebody is wondering with that, um,
what kind of questions does council have?
So, uh, okay, one question. So the— so looking at
the whole concept as opposed to just the affordable
housing Lots, the lots outside of that.
I think they are supposed to, supposed to average a half acre. Is that correct?
The remainder? And is that still the case with the lots that are
still outside of the affordable housing? Do they still average a half acre?
Triumph Phase A, Plat 1 has
just come in and it takes into account the lots, the northeast,
basically, of the pie that you see on the screen right now.
And so with that, we'll start reviewing it. But as
the other final plats come in, then we will look for conformance
to that standard. And if there's a need to exercise some bit
of change, then the developer, I'm sure, will propose something that
the city can review.
Okay. Any other questions from council? There were a
lot of things that we discussed about this. In our work session,
is it at a point where we could make a motion and direct
some things? I've got some commentary on the language that would—
so maybe some comments and some— I don't know if you want me to bring
that up now or not. Yeah, we'd love to hear it. Section— so looking at
the deed restriction 2.05, it uses the
word conjunctive, and I believe that it was intended to be injunctive.
So I think we need to change that word.
3.06 has 2 3.06s, and so the
numbering is incorrect after that. So that would need to get changed as
well. If you look at
4.04, it references
Article 5, but I believe that it was intended to reference
Article 4.
And actually, let's see, did I say that on 5.01? So that's 4.04.
There's that error in 5.01. I believe also it
references Article 5 when I believe it's meant to reference Article 4.
And then let's see here. Can you repeat
that one, please? That one. So Articles 4.04
and 5.01 both reference Article
5 in the verbiage when they— I think they intended to reference
Article 4. Way faster than I can type.
Reference Article 5.
You're not hearing
the stuff on the microphone, but we're just helping the person who's making
the motion get all the details. So Um, and then there, uh,
shoot, I gotta find this in all my notes here.
7.02, the word foreclosure is misspelled in the last
sentence of 7.02.
See,
okay, those are the corrections. Then I've just got some There's
one more— some questions. Sorry, there's one more correction, and then we'll head to your
questions. In the amendment, um, Section 2.2.5,
it talks about— it spells out the word— the words 53,
but then puts the numerals for 56, and it should
just be 53 and 53, because when this was approved,
that's what our standards were, um, or at least set
so that they match each other. It's not a big one, but I wanted to
make sure we brought that one up. Okay, Councilmember Whiting, what are your other thoughts?
And this is just maybe for clarification in the contract. So I think it's Section,
uh, 6.02, if I remember right,
that it says the city can delegate numerous aspects of the administration
of this, the deed restriction, to other entities,
and does say accepting a few different things. And I just want to make
sure that That Article 4 cannot be delegated by the city.
And Article 4 does, and I think the verbiage is probably in that section,
but Article 4 is what specifies that the city from time to time could
modify various aspects of it, including the multiplier that's used
and, and pretty much many other things in there. I just want to
make sure that Article 4 is not something that, that could be considered
as— that could be delegated elsewhere. Okay.
And then on Section,
let's see,
3.04, it mentions
some aspects, you know, some circumstances in which a transfer
could occur without qualifying income. And I
know it's stated above in a prior section, if someone
receives ownership on
a transferred basis where qualified income was not used,
I still want that person to know there is a primary occupancy
required. So let's say a father passes away and
wills the property to the son. The son doesn't live there.
At that point, it's a breach that the son's got. In other words, the son's
going to have to sell. So you're saying that there should be a due-on-sale clause
in here? Well, um, just a reminder that transfer—
that if you received this through— if you received the property
through one of these ways stated in, uh, where it's not
qualified, where you don't need to check income, you still have to— if you received
ownership, you still got to live there as a primary occupant. So we got to
put that into verbiage here. So what's the best way to do that? You're going
to— you're going to say the requirement. So it's transferred by death,
heirs, whatever that might be. There's a requirement to be a
primary— Uh, you still— yeah, if you're the reviewer,
and if not, then it should trigger what, a do you want to sell or
a requirement to sell? It would. Sorry, it would.
Yes. So how— we probably need to put some language in there. You know,
I mean, I, I under— I understand and I agree. And,
and I'm— and it may, it may, you know, it's probably— if
you look at other areas of the whole deed, it says in all cases this
has to be primary Ownership occupied, but I think in
this specific section it would be useful to reference because I could see this happening
where someone dies. It now passes like let's
say let's say will it I'm living there will it to one of my kids
who's not living there I die the kid's gonna now own it not living
there I think it's nice in this section to state you're gonna have
to sell it because you're not living there or move to that or move
to into or move into it just just that there is a Requirement that it
be, that it be owner occupied. Yeah,
do we need to add in a lot more language
or just clarify the very specific requirement of owner occupancy?
Yeah, I just, so I think 3.04, just stating
that if someone receives title under Section 3.04,
that— How does this language work? Notwithstanding the foregoing,
this section is the very last sentence would be added. this section does not
alter, change, or otherwise affect the owner occupancy requirement. That sounds awesome.
Awesome. Leave it to the attorney to make it simple. Thank you,
Marcus. All right, so do you have
any other items on your list? See, and Council
Member Wood, I hope that you're getting ready to make this motion.
Okay, does anyone else have thoughts that they'd like to share before
While Councilmember Whiting's finding the rest of his thoughts.
Oh, we— you ready? So, okay, so here's the other
question I want to ask the council. Is the LMI homebuyer
definition 80% of AMI or less
at the time of contract? In my mind,
it should be at the time of closing, because what
if they go under contract with whether— what— with whatever income and
during the contract period, you get a promotion.
Are we still going to let that person close?
They, they're now above the 80% AMI. So,
and maybe, maybe, maybe this is, maybe this is an underwriting thing. Maybe underwriters are
just— maybe we just go back to what the underwriters are doing on this.
I think, I think we go with contract. So, at the time of contract,
so you don't really care what happens during the contract period? I mean, in the
life of these properties. Parties over time, it's going to always revert back
to the AMI. Look, I think assuming they sell— I mean, I'm going to speak
not from the real estate side of things, and I'm grateful that you 2 are
digging into the details of the deed restriction, and I asked you to do that,
Craig, and I'm grateful you did. Um, I knew you would. Um,
from my perspective, at the time of a contract
is okay for this reason, because if something changes in that
time frame and Certainly it could. Does it really matter?
Because I think what we want to do is give assurance to the developer that
he has a qualified applicant, that there's funding in place to make this happen.
And my anticipation is, is that these are going to all happen boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom. Unless that is a requirement
of underwriting and now they don't qualify. Because,
because, because— so do they pull, do they pull income verification like
at contract? then at closing. Yeah, you're not going to lock into anything
until you're close to your— the end of the— especially with this being a build
in the very beginning, for sure it's not going to be till the end,
right? In the resale, that's not the case. But you
have 2 problems, right? That's, that's a good question. Um,
Abby Ivory is giving us an indication that she has some
information to share. She's also a mortgage broker.
Is that what So, well, and we're just loaded down with
them. Okay, we've got a little bit of input here. Um,
so I do, I have experience as a— I'm a current mortgage broker.
I own my own company, so I do have a little bit of knowledge about
this. I've been doing loans since 2001. So, um,
they will only get qualified for income 1 time. So by
the time closing comes around, they just try and see if they're still employed.
So they're not going to check income again, but you could say at the
time of contract, just like you would anything else, you know, their ability
to qualify for something would be at contract, but you wouldn't really have
to do anything more than that. Okay, so they're not doing income
verification at the end? They do it as part of the
process, part of the loan process, but when you get ready to close, all they're
doing is just making sure that they're actually They
don't check income again,
even if they're in some kind of affordable housing program.
They just can't keep doing that over and over, so they just
do it once. Any other questions for our expert mortgage broker?
The layman had it right. All right,
thank you for sharing your insights. I just— I have a question,
just timing-wise. This would be for the applicant. Are you
building and selling them as,
like, in other words, typically, is this going to be a 30-day close? Are you
going under contract before the lot comes, like, the home comes out of
The intention is we may release these right
towards the end when some colors or textures could be chosen.
But this is not like a pre-sold build job. These are spec homes. We don't
really want to deal with the buyer through the construction process. We're going to choose
everything, or our designer will pick most everything. So some might have
a choice on maybe carpet or flooring or paint
color, but there shouldn't be any kind of— I
don't know how I would verify any kind of subsequent disqualification,
Craig, if, you know, if they qualified at the beginning and then
30 days later when they're ready to close, I don't even know how we would
check it again. Because the process to vet them in the
beginning is pretty significant. And I don't know that we would do that
again 3 or 4 or 5 weeks later. So it's a pretty short timeframe
from when we vet them and approve them to when they're closing on the home.
Yeah. All right. Any other questions or comments from council?
Yes. So more, more for your motion here. So I believe that
we— well, council member, right? There, I think
there was a discussion with the applicant regarding,
uh, well, regarding, uh, what was going to be included with the home. So landscape,
full landscaping, full fencing, fencing. Was that also, or just landscaping?
The list, sure, just so we can— so purchase price inclusions that could,
could be included in the development agreement. Uh, full landscaping front
and back, fencing. Um,
can we say water-wise landscaping? It is water-wise
landscaping. Yes, water-wise landscaping. Um,
all appliances, including refrigerator, washer, and dryer,
and all window coverings.
That includes a microwave? Mhm. Okay, this one, I mean,
all appliances.
Well, back in the day, I remember selling homes in Eagle
Mountain where there was no air Air condenser, air conditioning condenser unit.
I don't remember that. Some of those just— oh, you want their conditioner? That's sold
additional. They'll all have AC and condenser units. Yes, thank you. And furnaces.
AC, or excuse me, uh, electric ranges.
Uh, most likely, yes. Okay, and then, and then another on the, on the,
uh, on your, uh, motion that the approval
would have pertained to Pod 1, but I, I don't know if Pod 1's defined
As which of those 4 pods it is? Yeah, it's the northernmost
pod. Northernmost. That's the first cluster. It's the only one that we've actually designed.
Okay. The other ones we'll show you as we go because our product mix
might change up a little bit. Each lot is specific for
the footprint of the home, just for maximum efficiency.
So, they'll kind of evolve a little bit as we go into the others.
And we've only fully designed 3 plans. We will design and engineer
more when, you know, if this is a go. So, and 14,
that was phase 1. Yes. Well, it won't be
in our first plat. It'll be in our— it'll be in plat 2. Yeah.
All right, before I entertain a motion, I'm gonna invite
John Magnus to start making his way up because we're gonna get
you in a second. We've got, we've got a record to break. Okay.
I will be texting Mayor Gray to let him know. Anyway,
Councilmember Hewish, did you have another item? Sorry. We got
it. You got it covered. Okay. Is there anything you need to say about the
water? Was there any other additional?
So let me read these to you, then everybody can make their— whether
we agree or not. What was in 2.25? I didn't—
that one you went too fast on.
No, that is under 2.05.
What was 2? That was changing 53 feet
to 53 feet within the brackets,
um, which, yeah, I've already done. So,
all right,
okay, so 2.25, change 52 The
words 53 feet and the number in parentheses,
53 feet, to match. 3.1, to specify
as long as RDA funds are available for
the purchase of the water,
uh, in the deed restriction and affordability covenant.
Articles 2, 2.05,
conjunctive changed to injunctive.
Article 3, 3.02.
What was the one? I got that down, but I don't remember what that was.
Was that the fixed numbering one? No, that's— let's
see, 3.02.
I had— oh, this was the, uh, the question that we talked about in the
previous, uh, meeting about who is going to,
uh, be the person to administer. The deed
restriction. Do we want to leave it as it
is? Do we want to have that changed to something else? I'm comfortable
with it as is. I think it gives us the chance of choosing,
right? But I
didn't have any questions on— you guys good with the language in
that one? I didn't have any questions, especially since we'll get to see it again
after when they go to pod 2. Okay,
Article 3, 3.04, as changes stated by our Eagle Mountain
City attorney, including owner occupancy requirement.
Article 4, 4.04 and 5.01 to reference Article
4 instead of Article Uh,
in the amendment to the MDA,
uh, to include amenities, fencing, water-wise landscaping,
all appliances that include washer, dryer, microwave range,
and refrigerator.
And then approvals applicable to the northernmost pod in Plat
2. Okay, and then the numbering from 3.06
onward, the numbers are incorrect. So fix the numbering from
3.06 forward. And then— Is that in the amendment?
That's in the deed restriction. In the deed restriction.
Just a sec. Fix numbering
from 3.06
onward. Onward. Okay. And then I think 6.02
is probably what you were looking for. So 6.02,
that it'll specifically specify that Article 4 cannot
be— that the city cannot— that the city cannot delegate
the terms of Article 4.
All right. Would a motion— Just
a second. I want to make sure I got it. So Article 6,
6.02, city cannot delegate for— there's
an Article 4, 6.02. It's 6.02, Article 4 can't be
delegated, right? That doesn't make sense.
It'd have
to be Article 6 because they're numbered that way.
All right.
Okay, Article 6, 6.02, city cannot delegate authority.
Is that correct? They cannot delegate.
Let's see, its responsibilities under
Article 4. Because Article 4
gives an ability to do a
whole bunch of changes. It gives the city unilateral
ability to do that, and we don't want to delegate that right to anybody
else under the delegation of authority mentioned in 6.02.
Okay, so Article 6, 6.02, city cannot delegate
its responsibilities under Article 4, correct?
Okay, does the motion need to state all the things that he just stated,
or can the motion say as stated?
No, I'm going to say them all. I want to be clear. All right,
go for it. Let me just do quick organization
here. This is Rich we're talking about.
Okay, yeah, I did one motion 6 times in a row last time, just so
we're clear. Mayor Pro Tempore, we entertain a motion.
Yes. I move that the City Council approve an
approval of Second Amendment to the Triumph Master Development Agreement for the Triumph subdivision
with the following changes.
In the Triumph MDA 2nd Amendment,
adding the language for included amenities to
be fencing, water-wise landscaping, all appliances
including washer, dryer, microwave, range, refrigerator.
This is specific to The northernmost
pod in plat 2 only
for approvals. In 2.25
of the amendment, change the spelling
from 53 feet and
parentheses 53 feet to match. In 3.1,
specifying the RDA funds. Or excuse me,
the purchase of water as long as RDA funds are available.
Moving to the deed restriction and affordability covenant, fixed numbering
from 3.06 onward. Article 2,
2.05, change conjunctive to injunctive.
Article 3, 3.04,
making changes as stated by the city attorney, including an owner occupancy
requirement. the end. Article 4,
4.04 and 5.01, to reference Article 4
instead of Article 5. And Article 6,
6.02, city cannot delegate its responsibilities under
Article 4. And, and one more item real quick, if you'll
take an amendment. Article 7.02, the foreclosure
is misspelled in the last sentence, to correct the spelling.
All right, so we have a motion. Second. With an assist from
Council Member Wood, with some assistance, and then a second from Council Member Wright.
Are there any questions or discussion? Finish my motion, you jumped.
Oh, okay. Article 7 foreclosure
is misspelled. Second.
Thank you for that clarity, Council Member Wood. All right, so we have
a motion from Council Member Wood, a very fastidious motion,
and a second from Council
Member Wright, are there any discussions left that we need to have about this particular
motion? I, I think just a statement for me in that
this is a test. This is not setting precedence anywhere
else in the city, that there's not an expectation, I think, for anyone
else, this, like, or just circumstances where we'll,
we'll turn a bunch of half-acre communities into, into affordable housing. This is just a
we're going to try this out and see what's happening in this specific circumstance,
unique circumstance, and that this action today
is not intended to set some kind of a precedence.
Thank you for that addition. Any other questions or comments?
All right, we'll begin the vote with
Council Member Wright.
Yes. Council Member Clark is a yes. Yes.
Whiting was a yes. Go ahead, Councilmember Wood. Yes.
Councilmember— yes. All right,
that's 5 yeses and that passes. Thank you. All right, so now we're
going to invite our management and policy analyst John Magnus
up to provide us with an update.
Good evening, Mayor Pro Tem, council members. I'm gonna make this short,
quick. One of the legislative priority items that we had on
there was Councilmember Woods— Wood, sorry— was about
when we get the development agreements and they come back at the last minute and
want changes. I talked to the state attorney.
Basically, parties to a contract can try to renegotiate at
any point in time. Trying to make a blanket statement saying we're going to deny
it would not be a good policy because it's a one-size-fits-all,
and maybe there is a reason. They need to come back and we need to
work with them. So I'm looking for direction. Do we take it off the list?
I mean, I'm gonna be honest with you, I can't even remember talking about this.
I'm trying to remember why this was a big deal. This has to do with—
I think it's Eagle Crest East was kind of the instigator for
them coming back, and others that have come back waiting to the very last minute
before it expires or whatever. I mean, we can create
a policy, but We're just not, you know, the council's not under any obligation
to actually follow that policy, because if they, under the circumstances, say, you know,
in this case, it actually makes sense to renegotiate the development agreement at
the last minute, then they would just do that. Um,
because parties can always amend a contract, uh,
you know, as long as both parties are willing. And it's just hard
to enforce such a policy, um,
because again, if, if Under
the circumstances, the city council at the time wants to do it, they'll do it.
And if they don't, they won't. And if somebody comes in last minute and,
and that's the reason they deny it, then that's the reason they deny it.
If somebody comes, you know, somebody comes early on and they still want to
deny it, they'll still deny it. It's just really hard to, uh,
to bind future council action in that way,
especially when you don't know the given circumstances for why it's being
asked for. I'm trying to remember what I wanted out of that,
and honestly, that didn't provide any clarity to me. I don't even remember. So probably
take it off because I can't recall why. You were very frustrated at the fact
that they were coming at the last minute and you want us— because it wasn't
the first time this has ever happened to the city, wasn't the last time,
and probably will keep going forward. They keep coming back for more extensions or
something like that. And so creating like a policy is problematic
because maybe there is a legitimate reason. John, I could have been wrong. It's possible.
So maybe just take it off. Okay.
All right, I said maybe.
Now I love it. We're gonna jump
over to the council's legislative priority for state legislation.
Evan's gonna give a quick presentation, then I'll follow that up with someone else.
Cool. Lightning round. Evan Barrett. Yeah,
we're gonna just tag team real quick. I'm just kind of inserting myself here just
to kind of Uh, this kind of came as we did our agenda prep meeting.
Um, Councilmember Clark kind of brought up the fact that John and
I kind of have this understanding of what the process should look like, or could
look like, uh, for trying to prepare the city council for the
next upcoming state, um, legislation round. Um, we want
to make sure that we're proactively preparing for that. We have your priorities,
um, in order and prioritized and everything like that, and that we're
working well as a team. Um, but like I said, John and I have an
idea of what that looked like, but we didn't actually convey that to you to
make sure that you're on board with that. So, um, I just have some printed
versions of what that looks like.
Um, so just to run through this really quick, because we, we Been through some
of this already, and, and feel free to modify
this or provide any feedback. But we've broken this down into basically
3 phases here. Again, this is— we're looking at this as like a year-round
process because this keeps coming around and around and around, right? And so John
had already reached out to you a while ago, worked and met with you individually
to get some of your individual feedback as far as certain
issues that you wanted to bring up any sort of concerns, any sort of things
that you want to tackle at the state level. And so that was meant to
really give an opportunity not just to hear what you had to say, but also
work with us to say, you know, hey, this is something that's of concern,
but I need to know more. So let's do some research together. Let's work out
some things. Let's, let's collaborate on that. And so that
all that information came back to John and I, and then we work with
our lobbying team to also vet them any information they know
or any advice that they have. We're at this point now with the
prioritization phase where we're coming to you, and John will get back up and present
with what has been collected from each of you individually.
But we want to start prioritizing those things. What do we really want to focus
on? We also want to do this with you on a regular basis, this kind
of phase, this prioritization phase, multiple times over the next few
months as we get closer to January, so that as new issues
come up, as new things change or whatnot, that we're relooking at that prioritization
and constantly preparing for that. Once we have that,
everything solidified and finalized, we have all our preparations in, in,
in place, then we divide and conquer,
but still coordinate, where John and I work on putting together
a lot of the, the code writing, the legislative one-pagers, all the different
materials that go into supporting our lobbyist team. The lobbyist team then becomes—
I like to put it— our strike team. They're the ones that go out and
get a lot of the work done, um, along with John and I, but also
the mayor and the council as well. Um, and then in that last
part of it, uh, at the full council at the bottom, we obviously want to
make sure that we're reporting back on outcomes as they happen.
Um, and at the final part of that, this whole thing is meant to be
not necessarily linear. You can cycle back through if there's other things you want
to talk about individually, you want to get research on whatever we can do that.
But in my mind, this is how it's all meant to be laid out.
We want to take individual interests and things like that, but then we also want
to make sure that we're all working together towards agreed-upon and cohesive goals
so that we're not all over the place. Um, and this is also
not to say that if the council, uh, you know,
sets a priority for things and something that you individually really feel passionate
about is, is not listed on that priority, at the end of the day,
it doesn't mean you can't go out and still push for that. We'll still support
you and whatever you need to do that. They just may not be the full
city's resources pushed towards for that. So,
just how my mind works, I like to categorize
things. When you guys are going and looking at what bills
are coming out, how is that presented to you? Are you pulling that information from
committees? Where are you getting— is that what— is that where it's coming from,
is committees? As far as the state level? where the bills come from.
Yeah. So we're— I think we're in a really much better position than
we've ever been now, just because we've been at the Capitol, we've been participating
with the committees, we've been very— working very close
with the league, the cities and towns and whatnot. And so, John and
I have been at the committee meetings making sure we're hearing it there. We're having
opportunities to talk with the committee members and things like that. And so—
That kind of lends to the next part of my question.
Sometimes it's hard when you come to us and say, well, what matters to you?
Yeah. And having that question posed to you and you're trying to go,
okay, you know, of all the different categories, what things matter?
For me, at least, it would be helpful as you're going through this process.
You guys are probably separating things out. Say, okay, these are in education,
these are in, you know, whatever they might be. If you could share it with
us in that form. I think it would probably help us facilitate the conversation
better to you to say, oh, education. Yeah, I remember this is something
that mattered to me. I want to talk about this. Or this is transportation,
uh, you know, B and C roads or, or whatever. I think that helps
us to give you better input rather
than on the spot. We kind of freeze and go, you know, I don't know,
you just tell us what you think is important. But I think you need help
too to say, okay, what should we focus on? Um, because you can't focus on
everything. Yep. But maybe that's just one of the suggestions I would make.
And we, we have the ability— I mean, AI is a powerful thing to help
us to be able to go through and summarize some of those things.
So you're not spending all your time chasing some of those things. We can do
some of those things. But if we at least understood, you know, here we're going
to go look at the committees. So the Transportation Committee, the Government Affairs Committee,
you know, whatever those might be, here are the bills that they're looking at.
doing, that gives us the ability to come back to you and say, this one's
important, this one's important. I appreciate that feedback. And,
and you mentioned AI briefly. John can talk about a lot more,
but we do have access to a great tool that is dedicated specifically
for this purpose, which actually allows freeing up a lot of
John's time so that we can be a little bit more,
again, proactive. But, but there's, there's the one side of this where
there are bills being created right now. There's bill files open, there's legislation And
so on that side, we're somewhat reactionary to those things.
We're trying to see what can we do to influence, to mitigate some of the
impacts to that, and how can we insert things. But the other side of my
mind is, what is it that we're now trying to influence at
the outset? You know, what can we start to instigate to create our own bill
files? How can we work with Stephanie Grecious and Heidi
Baldry and all these others to do things of our own? Yeah.
Um, and that's something that we haven't been able to do or haven't really done
much of previously. And so there's, there's both angles of it,
but we can be a lot better for sure at providing more information
of what's coming down the pipeline and how can we influence that and things like
that. So there's a lot more information we can provide you. Do we need to
have something in this flowchart where we are including Representative
Grecious and Buss, Baldery? How does that communication
happen that our needs are getting To them, or is it just more informal,
us reaching out to them? Yeah, I, I kind of, for, for sake
of space, I kind of group them as part of the lobbyist team, even though
they're not lobbyists. They're still kind of part of that same group
as far as their overall function in my mind.
But— Okay, any other questions for these guys? I know that
it was discussed that possibly we'd revisit
1A to see if there was an action— not an action, uh, direction given from
council as a body. And that was the overview of the
Best Friends Animal Society programs. Is there any desire to formalize
direction to staff as a body,
or— My personal opinion is I think we need to study
that more. I think there's some holes in that with Some of the recommendations
once, you know, a cat has been taken into custody
of how they're gonna release them. I think there's— I would like to have a
conversation about what are the consequences of just
following exactly what that said, because one of the things I was
telling Councilmember Whiting, they've been picked up for
a reason. They've— they're a nuisance. They're tearing up people's garbage.
They're fighting with their cats. They're somebody else's responsibility that's
now become a homeowner's problem. So I think we need to make sure before
we just go straight forward and say, you know, all cases, we're always
going to do this. We need to put some brackets in there that there are
things more than just they're a danger. There probably ought to be some other things
in that as well. Okay. Thank you, Councilmember Wood. Oh, sorry. I was going
to say they are willing— I mean, just in their commentary, they said they're willing
to customize a community. CAP program.
So I think the— so I think maybe the motion would be for
us to engage in discussions with them and to have them begin implementing,
or at least just having discussions with us to see how they can be— how
they can improve things with us, especially where the cost to us right now
is zero, which is nice. This is
just a discussion item, so you'd be making a motion to have Our
legislative team spend time on it. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and I'm supportive of, like, because I know they've got their code that
they proposed, and we didn't really debate or discuss or digest the entirety
of that code. So I agree that we need to look at that. But I,
but I, but I feel comfortable enough to make a motion that the— it's
added to the legislative priorities list that the city begin working with
Best Friends Animal Society.
And I'm not exactly— I mean, I don't want to, like, define the parameters necessarily.
Let's start discussions with them on the various resources
they presented to us, and then let's— I think we start— let's start moving that
ball forward. All right, so we have a motion. I'll second.
From Councilmember Whiting and a second from Councilmember Hewish.
Are there any questions about the motion or discussion?
I'm wondering if it should be that specific that it's just this entity.
I mean, I recognize that they're offering to do something for free, but I just
wonder if we should just cast a wider net.
I— what I'm thinking, Councilmember Wright, I was thinking that as the
motion was made because I feel ill-equipped to know what our other
options are. And perhaps our next big thing
that we ask staff to do
is to bring back Some of that code for us to discuss as
a body, as a discussion item, and try to find out what our other
options are. Would you be willing to amend your motion to
remove some of that extra stuff? Well, I'm looking at, for instance, they've got a
fully funded trap, neuter, vaccinate, return program.
That's better than what we have now. We don't have that now.
And they will work with animal control to handle some of
their duties. Which may take off some pressure from the animal control people that we've
got. I, I just— so we have a motion that's on the table. I think
the main idea of this is, are we willing to let them go do the
research, not to get into details of this? Is that correct? That's what I
see the motion as, adding it to the legislative priorities list.
Is there— is Councilmember Wright— you don't— what
do you— No, look, I'm, I'm going to support it, Councilmember Whiting, but I mean,
I'll just state this. I— it's not something that is high on
my list of priorities, but if, if it's important to you and Council Member Hewish,
I certainly think that let's work on it. And if you can bring something back
that makes sense, then we'll, we'll decide as a council. It's not something
I'm going to spend a lot of time and energy on. Well, no, not— yeah,
I mean, it's, it's a— it's an element, right? It's an element in a big,
big grouping of elements that we work on. But I, I, I would love for
them to begin talking to our animal control All right,
and see if there's something we can do to help with them. All right,
so we have a motion and a second. Is there any other discussion?
All right, I think that it starts with me.
Council Member Clark is a yes. Yes.
Council Member Wood? No. Council Member Hewish? Yes.
Council Member Wright? Yes. Uh, that passes 4 to
1. Can I just make a comment on my no? Yes, I just think that
there are far more time-consuming things we should have our staff chasing after.
Uh, maybe this is— with it being a pet project like this, it might be
good for the, the individual. Yeah, I didn't mean it
that way, but that just to have the council members that feel strongly about that
to kind of do the legwork because the staff has got a lot on their
plate. I mean, I, I'm okay moving forward. This is no cost to
the city. I see it as a value add. I don't think we need to
to do a huge calorie burn. It's a pilot program. I,
I just don't see a net negative to adding this. It's reversible,
amendable. Okay, well, I think the thing that would be nice to know is what
kind of time could it save our staff? I mean, that to me is the
most interesting part of it, is what type of cost savings could it bring to
our staff? What time would it free up from our code enforcement and others?
So, I mean, that's the, that's the carrot part of it for me. All right,
so it sounds like we're clear on what needs to happen with that.
for legislative items. We'll move on to— oh, go ahead,
go ahead. Skipped one, one portion. Um,
this is a list of— I met with you guys in May to discuss things
going forward. The highlighted, we, we grouped them,
they're not in any particular order. Uh, so the highlighted, the bolded
ones— county government, city government, public safety, recreation— those are the kind of areas.
Ones underneath it are specific things that we— I discussed with different
members. Um, it goes down to— I
scroll down the list— education.
So I'm going to send this out tomorrow.
Um, what I like— You can cross off 34, that's been done.
34? Oh, line 34. Oh, rename crime.
Oh yes. So, um,
what I'd like you to do is Score
it 1 through 5, 1 being most important, 5 being least important. Score the
highlighted ones, the general areas, so we know which general areas to work in,
and then also score the ones underneath to see how important those are to you.
And then we'll take an aggregate of it. And I'll also be reaching out to
make appointments to discuss these things with you one more time and go over
what has transpired so far in the interim session and what we're seeing coming
forward. Um, one of the state assemblymen have already
opened up 25 bill folders. So he's the one that writes
a lot on housing. So it's gonna be a busy year for us.
And then he talked about the AI. We've got a contract with Civic Relay.
It's an AI that will read the bills, tracks them, tracks where they
are on the— and you all get access to it so you can read it.
It will summarize for you. You can make notes on it and they'll come back
to us. So what we're hoping this year, instead of me
having to write all these white papers, Is that when we get a bill that
we don't like, we can actually start writing legislation that we want
in it to change it and see if we can get someone to carry it
as an amendment. So, all right. Thank you.
All right. So now we're ready to move on to City Council and Mayor's
business and liaison reports. Thank you, Mr. Magnus, and thank you, Mr.
Barrett. Um, this time is set aside for City Council and
Mayor's comments, um, on city business
and for council members to report on their liaison assignments.
Councilmember Wright, can we start with you? Yeah, I'll keep it short.
I told you that the seniors are working on the pantry, trying to facilitate a
monthly donation from the seniors to them, those that can help.
And they've got a lot of activities coming up. They're doing very, very well.
DRC— I'm amazed by DRC. I think you
all know that. It's really an honor to sit there and listen to and watch
our staff interact with those applicants that come before them week
by week. Um, and then ULTC, there's a lot that we're
getting ready for with the, with the interim and what all that's going on there.
All right, so I will quickly report on Community Services Board
and the American Legion. Um,
the Community Services Board continues to amaze me with
all that they're doing and moving forward. So, um, we have a meeting
coming up tomorrow which I'm looking forward to. And then for
the American Legion, they had presented a proposed MOU
for us, and there was some discussion within council of
whether or not the $5,000 was like
something that they were asking for a donation of or what. But it
was $1,500. Is it $5,000?
I thought it was $1,500. It wasn't $5,000. You might be
right. $1,500. Yeah, yeah, it's $1,500. Sorry. Um,
In talking to them, it's less about the dollar amount and more about some
of their needs— flags for when soldiers
come home or for special holidays and funding
to help with the Veterans Breakfast— that
they added an additional one of funding to help with the Veterans
Christmas Dinner, which hasn't previously been on the list.
So my recommendation is to have a representative
from the Legion sit down with our event staff to kind of figure
those things out and to have someone from the admin team be
a part of that conversation. And then once they've discussed that, bring it back to
us for approval. All right,
Councilmember Whiting. Youth Council has a big water
fight to start, uh, right, right before the school
year starts. So August 5th, put in your calendars, in the I don't
remember if we have a specific time. 2 o'clock, 2 to 4 o'clock
at Corey Ride Memorial Park. And there are some
of us up here who are going to be in a dunk, getting dunked by
the youth and any angry developers or angry citizens. They're— Welcome.
Are also very welcome to come dunk us. Um, so excited
for that. And, uh, there's a lot of energy happening with the Youth Council right
now. And, uh, they're growing. Uh, Chambers doing
an awesome job, and it seems like there's a grand opening, it seems like
every single week somewhere, which is very impressive.
So we have 4 tomorrow— I mean, 4 next week. 4 next week.
It's crazy. It's awesome. All right, Council Member
Wood. Mine's gonna be short and sweet. Uh,
rodeo stuff's done, so we're looking forward to next year. Uh,
Lake Mountain School District Uh, identified a new
location and renamed A-TECH. Uh, I'm trying to remember what—
it starts with a B, but somehow I can't remember the name right now.
But that has been identified and a location, so that's exciting that we'll
have that in the new school district. Uh, they continue to expand
the administration, uh, to prepare for the takeover next
year in 2027. Uh, and then I'm behind
on Alpine School District. I'm watching that one on video. So thank
you, Council Member Wood. Council Member Hewish? Just echoing what you said
on the Community Services Board tomorrow night, 6 o'clock. I'll be here.
Yeah, you got to put on your racing shoes when you go to the Community
Services Board. Is there a dress code on the dunk tank, by the way?
I'll be coming back from a business meeting. Whatever you—
yeah, I'll— I will be in a swimsuit,
but okay, um, if you want to wear a suit I may be in full
soon. All right, is there anything else? Communication items?
We're good. All right, so then I entertain a motion to adjourn.
So moved. Second. All right, we have a motion
by Council Member Wood and a second by Council Member Wright. All in favor?
Aye. Aye. All right, that passes. We're adjourned, and it